علاقاتك وعملك نعم علاقاتك عمرك هذه اذا
اذا صممت بشكل منسجم مع قيمك ومع
ما تمارسه في حياتك اليوميه فانت قطعا
قاعد تعيش حياه انا اعتبرها حياه جيده
حياه مصممه بشكل جيد شوف اي واحد قاعد
يتشكى من الشغل او يتشكم العلاقه او يتشكى
من شيء الا وتجد انه فيه في عنده تضاربوا
وعنده مصادمات مع ذاته مو كل الناس عندهم
هذه الرفاهيه في اختيار وين اشتغل كيف
اشتغل من مديري هو
يعني اذا لقى وظيفه فالحمد لله يعني خلاص
انا بستبر على مديري وعلى طريقه العمل
وخلاص يعني فما هي رفاهيه اني نختار كيف
اشتغل
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح كلنا نبحث عن حياه مرضيه سعيده
تعريف الرضا والسعاده فالضاب وعام ويختلف
من شخص الى اخر فبعض الناس علاقته بوالديه
واهله هي الاهم والبعض يعني من خلال العمل
يحقق ذاته والى اخره من الاختلافات لكن
كيف نقدر نصل الى هذا الرضا يبدو لي صعب
لكن نقدر نعتبر ان الحياه رحله نقدر
نصممها بشكل يرضينا هذه الحلقه عن تصميم
نمط الحياه حلقه تساعدنا في فهم ليه وكيف
نصمم حياتنا وتعريف التصميم عند ضيفي هو
خلق وفعل الشيء بقصد فهل تعرف اصلا ايش
تبغى تسوي بعد سنوات تخصصك اللي بتدرسه او
وين بتشتغل او يتزوج او اي بيت تشتريه او
هل تشتري بيت او ما تشتري بيت اصلا
والقرارات اللي تصمم حياتك تبدا ولا تنتهي
هل الخطط اللي تختارها وتتمناها في حياتك
تلتزم فيها
والاسئله كثيره ضيفي قادر على شرحها
وتبسيطها وتقديم حلول غير معلبه ضيفي
البراء العهلي المهتم والباحث في مجال
تصميم نمط الحياه واللي يقدم في هذه
الحلقه ادوات تساعدنا نصمم حياتنا بشكل
ينسجم مع قيمنا ورغباتنا في هذه الحياه
قبل ان نبدا في هذه الحلقه تحدثنا عن
تصميم نمط الحياه كيف يساعد في تحسين حياه
الانسان وجوده حياه الانسان لكن اذا كنت
تبغى تعيش هذه الحياه بدون
امراض او كيف تكون حياتك افضل لما تكبر
انصحك بالاستماع لحلقه فنجان مع الدكتور
ادم بطاينه تحدثنا عن
الشيخوخه والامراض المرتبطه فيها وعن فكره
ابطاء التقدم بالعمر وتاخير الشيخوخه
والوقايه منها تلقاها في وصف هذه الحلقه
اما الان لنبدا اتوقع الناس اغلبهم
يعرفونك
من خلالها هي سناب شات ايام سناب شات فهو
من الاشياء برضو تعلقت فيها
وتركتها مختلف الموضوع سناب شات يعني فيه
مو بستعلم احس انها صارت
كذا جزء من الهويه يعني كذا هويه
وهذا شيء جدا ما عجبني يعني او حسيت انه
مو بالشيء اللي ابغى اعرف فيه يعني اني
اعرف في تطبيق او اعرف ان اظهرك مكانه
يعني
في سياق سناب شات مو بموضوع انه والله
تعلقت فيه فتركته مثل الكافيين موضوع اخر
يعني لا هي سياقها انها اداه كانت جميله
مفيده في وقت ما زال يعني ممكن تكون مفيده
حتى اليوم لو لو بستخدمها في سياق محدد
يعني بس انها
يعني تغيرت عندي السياقات وصارت صرت في
سياق مختلف وحسيت انها قاعده تطرني اكثر
ما تنفعني بطريقه
يعني
مختلفه من اهمها كان عندي التركيز ما كنت
اقدر اركز يعني كانت يعني تزيد عندي تشتت
تزيد عندي يعني بالذات في ذاك الوقت انا
كنت يعني ما عندي الا الجامعه وعندي باقي
نمط حياتي اقوم الصبح اركض اطبخ لحالي
عزوبي ما عندي شيء مو بس ما عندي شيء اقصد
انه
يعني ما في تبعات لاني اكشف حياتي
والخصوصيه هذه بعد موضوع الثاني
كنت يعني فكنت ماخذ الموضوع بساعه وكان
عندي الجلد والوقت لصناعه محتوى ما احب
الي الا غصب عشان تصير موجود كل يوم لازم
تصنع محتوى كل يوم يعني ترتيب اولويات
تغير من من فصل الفصل يعني كنت مغصوب
يوميا تمثل المحتوى وتشعر بهذا مغصوب عادي
يعني بس تشعر بالضغط انك لازم تسوي محتوى
يوميا ولا هي جزء لانك انت توثق حياتك
كنت منتاب في موضوع التوثيق اليومي لان
كنت يعني اذكر كنت اقولها بذاك الوقت كنت
استخدمها كاداه
لاتدرب على مهاره السواليف مهاره السرد
القصصي كنت اسميها وساعدتني ايضا في البحث
حق ماجستير فكانت في اداه للبحث حقي انت
تستخدمها في بحث يعني جزء من الفرضيه حقتي
او الموضوع البحثي كان هو موضوع عن
البرنامج كنت ادرس تصميم الوسائط
الجامعه هناك وكان بحثي تحديدا عن كيف ان
السرد القصصي يؤثر او يساعد الناس على
انها تتمنى عدد جديده وكنت استخدم يعني
عاده الركض وكيف انه صعب الواحد يحكي قصه
هو يركب مثلا او هو يسوق سيكل وهو طالع
مغامره او هو يقدم اي رياضه لان
يعني لازم تركز انت يعني انك تؤدي رياضه
او انك تصور او انك
فهذا نوعا ما الملتي تاسكنج اللي كان عندي
او تعدد في اني احيانا احكي قصص اصور
المقاطع اتعب احيانا في اني اوقف والقى لي
لقطه واصور من جهه
فالناس قاعده تشوف شيء ايا كان هذا الشيء
سواء كان شخص قاعد يركض او شخص قاعد ياكل
او شخص قاعد يرقص او ايا كان قاعد يسوي
الناس في عندها شيء بعد عميق يسمونها
اللي هو الرغبات المقلده انا لما اشوف احد
قاعد يسوي شيء احس كذا جيتيني رغبه اني
ابغى اقلد واذكر يعني من المحادثات اللي
تصير مع كثير من الناس ما اعرفهم اللي
يقول الامان والله تحمس اجرب اركض ولا
اتحمس اجرب ايا كان نمط الحياه
اجرب اجل اليابان لان اغلب تصويري كان في
وقتها وقت الدراسه
فهذا كله قاعد يثبت شيء اللي هو هذه اللي
صدق وانا شخصيا انا اشوف اتاثر كثير باللي
أشوفه على يعني على سواء على السوشيال
ميديا وعلى اللي اقرا عنهم او في الافلام
اي قصه اسمعها
فهي شيء حقيقي واقعي كانت ادافع عاليه
يعني بس متى استوعبت انه صار يضرك هل هي
اللي علاقته بالهويه اللي انت قلتها ولا
اثر عليك لان تشتت ولا
وين النقطه اللي قلت انا الان لازم اوقف
لانه بقرار سهل
يعني هي ما اتوقع انها جت كذا لازم اوقف
الان بعدين سويت كذا بيان سوف نتوقف يعني
ما هي بكذا هي جت تقريبا تدرج
وجت تدرج هذا مع انتقالي يعني بعد التخرج
خلصت جت فتره انتقاليه اذكر حتى كنت مازلت
اصور وقتها كنت اسوي شيء
او السفر المهم لازم يكون في مشروع عاده
عشان يكون عندي مبرر اني اصور قصص يوميا
والى الى مؤخرا ترى يعني انا ما قطعت
تماما يعني يمكن سناب شات من جد يعني بعد
عندي مشكله معاه انه تصميمه سيئه صراحه
بالنسبه لي يعني
لكن قللت في السوشيال ميديا بشكل عام يمكن
احيانا اوثق بعض القصص على انستجرام لما
اطلع رحله او لما يكون عندي مشروع معين او
يكون عندي
شيء معين اقدر امشي معاه بقصه يوميه او
بقصه متكرره وبعدين لما ارجع لنمط حياتي
العادي وتحديد لما رجعت السعوديه في 2017
تقريبا
صار عندي نمط حياه مختلف ويتطلب خصوصيه
اعلى ويتطلب احيانا تركيز على اشياء اكثر
وتغير عندي هذا
اللي كل يوم يعني اذكر من الاشياء اللي
كانت مشعله عندي في لما كنت في اليابان
انه حرفيا كنت يوميا
جديد لكن الجو مختلف وايضا حساسيه
الخصوصيه هنا مختلفه هنا كل يوم او كل
يومين أنت غالبا في نفس المدينه مع ناس
اخرين
انا على الاقل عندي يمكن حساسيه عاليه اني
ما ودي يعني اعلم او اتكلم دائما انا وين
الحين ولا مع مين
يعني مختلف وقت انت عزوبي لحالك الحين معك
اهل معك ناس معك فهي جدا شيء
يعني لو
دقائق اللي قبل شوي يمكن قلت نمط الحياه
يعني خمس مرات
قاعد تحسب
للموضوع هذا الموضوع الحلق الى حد يعني ما
بين نمط الحياه وتصميم الحياه او تصميم
نمط الحياه
بس يعني متى انت اصلا بديت تهتم بموضوع
اصلا نمط الحياه الاصل ان الانسان ما يهتم
يمكن يسوي اشياء تشكل نمط لحياته بس انما
يهتم بكيف انا
اصمم نمط الحياه او اني انا اصلا عندي نمط
لحياتي
يمكننا بس العمل استراحه البيت هذا نمط
بس وين بدل الموضوع يشغل بالك والله صحيح
يمكن
يعني تذكر احنا نعرف بعض من كم ست سنين
الحين من اول لقاء ما كنت اتكلم عن نمط
الحياه بالطريقه هذه
اعتقد من هذيك الفتره الى الحين يعني هذا
الفتره بدات تتضح عندي
خلني اقول انا قاعد اشوف مشكله عندي في
اني قاعد اعيش نمط حياه او في تحدي في
طريقه في الطريقه اللي قاعد اعيش فيها
حياتي
لا من جانب صحي ولا من جانب انا كيف قاعد
اقضي وقتي اتوقع ما تقدر تفصل نمط الحياه
عن كلامك عن كيف تكتب
ويمكن انا قاعد استخدم هالكلمه كثير
واستخدمها بشكل يعني لاني تشبعت بالكلمه
من كثر الطلاعي فيها واهتمامي فيها
ومحاوله فهمها وتفكيكها واعاده بناءها في
في شيء ممكن كثير منه يسويه وهو ما يدري
او ما يحس اللي هو انت كيف قاعد تخطط يومك
كيف قاعد تخطط جدولك وكيف قاعد تخطط
لحياتك
فتخطيط الحياه وعيشك الحياه هو مبني على
اصلا مش طريقه حياتك او نمط حياتك مثل ما
وصفت انا اروح الدوام اطلع اروح الجيم
اروح استراحه هذه كلها عباره عن عناصر
تركب فيها بشكل يومك اللي هو بالاخير
تراكميا حياتك
اعتقد البدايه بدات حرفيا من من المرحله
الانتقاليه هذه مع 2017 اشياء كثيره صارت
يعني الحين اللي هي انا خلصت دراسه طيب
الحين في كذا فجاه مساحه كبيره من حياتك
انت في بدايه الثلاثين
مش بتسوي
وش بتختار وايش وين بتكمل تتزوج ما تتزوج
طيب تشتغل هنا ولا بتطلع بتسافر بتكمل
دراسه الدكتوراه بتقعد ولا هذي كلها اسئله
رجع سؤال حق ثاني ابتدائي
هذا سؤال مؤرق اتوقع الكثير منه ويتغير
حتى نسخه السؤال هذا مع مراحل مختلفه
ويا كانت مشكله كبيره عندي يعني
فاقم هذه المشكله اللي هو
اني عندي
ميوله ونزعات احيانا لاني ابغى
الاشياء تصير مثاليه الحمد لله يعني ربي
انعم علي يعني ناس ناصحين حولي
وفرص ايضا
موجوده امامي وهذا يمكن يعني هي نعمه
ونقمه في نفس الوقت لان احيانا لما تكون
مضطر تساؤلات مو موجوده
خلاص يعني تسعه وتمشي بخط واحد لكن هذا
الخيارات تخليك احيانا تبغى الا تجيب احسن
خيار ومن حق كل واحد انه يختار الافضل
لنفسه بالعكس يعني
فكنت اتسائل ما في معاني ولا ما في شيء
يخلي الواحد يتخذ قرارات بشكل احسن يقول
والله انا ابغى اصمم شكل حياتي بحيث انه
يكون واحد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه كنت اتخيل
يعني وهذا بعد يمكن نشوفهم برا يقول فسكه
شوي يقول كنت اتخيل ابغى اعيش شوي هنا في
السعوديه بعدين شوي برا اشتغل كذا في
برامج السفر بعدين اشتغل شوي في التصميم
بعدين عندي وظيفه وعندي بزنس في نفس عرفت
تصمم وقعدت تحط طموحاتها تحط يعني خلينا
نقول كذا احلام لكيف طريقه وشكل حياتك
وبعدين اكتشفت انه هذا شيء حقيقي واقعي
لاي واحد يعني يبغى يخطط لحياته او في
سياقه يصمم نمط بشكل حياته انه يبدا او
يشتغل او فيه عمليه في ادوات تقدر
تستخدمها وتساعدك فيه انك توصل للشيء هذا
مو مو بس تحلم وتحاول وتشتغل فانا كنت
اتمنى انه القى الدليل المانيوال كيف تعيش
حياتك او كيف تصمم حياتك لكن للاسف ما
لقيت شيء يعني كذا بالساهل او بالطريقه
هذه
فمن هناك بدا الاهتمام
وقاعد يعني تقدر تقول
موضوع كذا موضوع البحث يعني اللي قاعد
اشتغل عليه يعني وبعدين بعدها طلعت الشر
مختلفه كثيره يعني
من اهم الاشياء اللي اذكر يعني تبلورت
وتغيرت عندي اني بديت افهم او حاولت افصل
اصلا حنا كيف كان
يعني انت الحين لما تتكلم عن نمط حياه ما
تقدر تتكلم عن نمط الحياه بدون ما تتكلم
عن انت كيف تقضي يومي انت عبد الرحمن من
قمت من الصبح للحين وش الساعه كذا كل ساعه
وش صار فيها وكيف اخترت انك تقري يومك
فيها هل قضيتها لان على البركه ولا بس قمت
من النوم قاعد اسوي رياكشن انا قاعد اسوي
تفاعل مع اللي يجي جاني اتصال ارد عليه
ولا عندك
روتين طقوس معينه عندك خطوات معينه قاعد
قاعد تلتزم فيها وتمشي عليها او صممتها
اخترت انك تحطها في البرنامج علشان توصل
لطريقه الحياه اللي تبيها يعني
صعبه جدا انك تقدر تعرف كيف تخلي يومك
يصير بالساعه بس
الايه يعني
على هالنقطه انا ودي اجل شيء مره مهم
انك ذكرتني فيها معلش بقطعك
ترى كثير من الكلام اللي بنقولها وممكن
بكرره بعد شوي
من الظاهر يبدو مثالي طيب بعدين يجي
الواقع الواقع الواقع يعني
فانا اول واحد اللي اللي احتاج دائما اسعى
اني اني احاول اقرب هالصوره المثاليه لاني
واعرف يقينا هذا مره مهم اعرف اعرف يقينا
انه ترى هذا الشيء كل يوم او حتى يمكن ولا
يصير ميه بالميه لكن هو على الاقل شيء هدف
تسعى له مثل الرؤيه اي اي احد يضع رؤيه من
احد الاشياء الرؤيه انك انت شيء تسعى انك
توصله الرؤيه الجيده هي الرؤيه اللي ما
تتحقق ابدا لكن دائما في سعي لها انك توصل
فهذا يخليك تتحطم انه انا كل يوم اصمم
جدولي او يومي بشكل المثالي اللي انا
ابغاه بعدين كل يوم اصلا ما اسوي
خلاص
حلو وهذا شيء يصير انا يصير معي كثير يعني
في اوقات معينه خصوصا لما ينخبص النوم
ينخبص الاكل فجاه يزيد المشاغل وبعدين
تيجي تقعد كذا نسوي اجتماع كذا نوقف ونشوف
وش وش
الجذر المشكله وتبدا اصلا هذا هو السعي
يعني التصميم نمط الحياه وسعي يومي ما
يخلص ما ينتهي ما هو يلا سوينا الجدول
خلاص انتهى نوقف كذا وبيشتغل الحاله لان
انا بشر مو مكاني هذا اول شيء والشيء
الثاني
موضوع السعي اليومي هذا هو جزء منه انه
كنت كل ما ابتعدت عن النسخه المثاليه او
عن الشيء اللي انت يعني خليني اتفادى
استخدم مثاليه بتكلم عن عن طريقه الحياه
اللي انت ترغبها
واللي بتخليك تعيش في حياه وكذا يعني في
نمط الحياه اللي انت تبيه
فتجي تكون ناظر وش المشكله وين المشكله
وتحاول تحلها وفي طرق لحل المشاكل يعني
هذه ايضا اصلا الموضوع كامل داخل تصميم
مضى الحياه اللي هو كيف تتعامل مع كيف تحل
المشكلات المشكلات اللي قاعده تضر او
قاعده تقف عقبه في انك تصل لها النسخه
الجيده او الحياه الرائعه اللي انت تبغى
تعيشها اجل خلينا نرجع للجذر حلو
ليه ليه اصلا ابغى اخطط حياتي وليه ابغى
اصمم
حياتي ليه اسوي كل هذا وش الهدف اللي انا
بحصل عليه اذا سويت هذا الشيء
يعني بدل ما قبل الفوائد انا بقول لك وش
مخاطر اني كنت ما تسويها شي
قلق لا لا يعني خلني نفترض انك
لا تصمم
هل متخيل انتم ممكن يصير
اقدر اقول لك انها تبغى تجاوب ولا تبغى
تعطيه الافتراض اللي عندك لا انا ودي اسمع
انت اول شيء انا اقول لك اني انا عامه حلو
بخطط اشياء عامه انا بقول اني
ابى ادرس
تسويقا لقانون
بسيط محامي بشتغل وبتزوج
ودي يصير عندي
يعني فلوس وخلاص يعني بس يعني خلاص حلو
هذا يعني هذا الشكل اللي انا اقدر اخطط له
هذا الشيء اللي انا ابغاه ليه وهذا نوع من
التصميم انت صممت بشكل يعني يعني تعتقد او
تشوف انه مثالي لحياتك طيب وبعدين مشيت
في الامور واكتشفت انه لحظه انا ما ابغى
ادرس السويق لحظه انا ليش دخلت
يجي موضوع مره مهم نقطه اساسيه في موضوع
التخطيط او انا احب اسميها تصميم اللي هو
انت قاعد تصمم شيء وما كنت عارف نفسك اصلا
اذا انتبه هالشي ولا لا طيب فلما اجي
اتكلم عن موضوع مثل تصميم نمط الحياه واحب
اسولف فيها مع الناس اللي يعني احس اكثر
الناس اللي يلقطون او يفهمون هالموضوع
اللي اصلا يعملون في مجال التصميم لان
كلمه التصميم يمكن نسمعها كثير اول ما يجي
على بالي او على بالي يمكن تصميم فوتوشوب
جرافيكس كده يعني كده شغلتنا بالتصميم
يعني لكن انا تعلمت شيء تحيده في مرحله
بعد دراسه الماجستير يعني واذكر اول ما
علمونا يعني يمكننا ندرس التصميم بمعناه
المجرد وليس التصميم الجرافيكس ولا تصميم
النظام
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
تصميم
يعني احب اعرفها بانها هي الخلق بقصد
ومعنى انت لما تكون قاعد تخلق شيء وانت
قاصد انك تسويه انا بصمم هذه الغرفه بحيث
انه يدخل ما يقدر يلف من هنا بس يمشي من
هنا انا بصمم هذا البيت انا بصمم حياتي
بحيث انه ما حد يقدر يكلمني الصبح لاني
قاعد اشتغل بطريقه معينه واروح من هنا
واجي من هنا انا ابغى اصمم علاقاتي بحيث
انه خلاص يصير بطريقه هذه التصميم ايش
قاعد يصير قاعد يقول انا قاعد اختار
بقصد ومعنى وهذا القصد معنا مبني على
اشياء على اشياء معلومات معينه شيء يعرفها
عن نفسي شيء اعرفه عن التبعات الاشياء عن
قرارات ممكن تؤثر وما تاثر فلذلك انا
دائما احب استخدم التصميم
ودائما تصمم الشيء اللي ايش اللي يهمك اذا
حياتك ما تهمك
خلها على البركه تمشي والله يكتب لك اللي
فيه الخير لكن فعلا تهمك
فعلى الاقل انك انت يعني مدين لنفسك انك
تسعى في جهد انك تصمم وتصمم اكثر من انك
تقول بس بدرس زين بتزوج وان شاء الله يعني
اذا جمعتكم قرش باخذ قرض
كانك تضع ايضا تصميم اكثر دقه يعني اشبه
يعني البيت مثلا بمن يعني يمكن انت بعد
حديث احد عن حديث عن البيت
ما انت تقول باخذ اي بيت وخلاص اذا انت
يهمك فعلا مكان عيشتك لتقضي فيه اغلب يومك
مع اسرتك ومع الناس اللي بتصمم تبغى تصمم
بيت تبغى بقصه معنا وش المواد اللي تحطها
على الجدران وايش البيبان وايش كيف دخلت
الغرف على بعض كيف دخلت الشمس بينما تجد
شخص اخر ما يهمل يعني فعلا في ناس ترى
معنا في مجتمعنا يعني البيت زين اهم شيء
يحميني من الاخبار من المطر يعني خلاص
اللي يجي يجي وهذا والناس تختلف يعني
فاعتقد يعني انا شخصيا والناس اللي ممكن
تتصل بالرساله هذه هم ناس هم فعلا تهمهم
حياتهم وطموحاتهم وكيف وقتهم قاعد يقرا في
الحياه هذه
فيجد يمكن اهميه او يجد انه او فعلا تصدق
انا احتاج اني اضع شويه وقت وسعي في اني
اصمم على الاقل لان هي من الاشياء اللي
انت تصممها مره واحده وبعدين تحتاجها
سياره بين فتره وفتره وهكذا تمشي يعني
الواحد يعني
يبغى اصلا لانها تتغير الافكار فيجي برضو
انه اذا انا بصمم اشياء
يعني لو برجع عشر سنين او لو ترجع ثاني
ابتدائي مش كنت ابغى قال لك دكتور يوم مصر
المتوسط
يعني عادي كل شوي يتغير صح تمام ولما تدخل
الجامعه وتدخل تخصصك يعني لنفرض يصممته
يعني وتعبت واتهمني حياتي لكني انا اكتشف
ان الواقع ان كل ما امر ان تصميمي غلط
اصلا يعني انا ما عاد ابغى التسويق ولا
ابغى او ما عاد ابغى الماليه انا كنت
اعتقد اني احب المالي ما احبها
اختلفت اختلفت المعادلات والمعاملات اللي
خلتني اصبر وعلى ذلك فقس يعني يمكن اكون
كنت احب السفر ومع الوقت ما عاد
فشخصيتي تختلف
من يعني من فتره لفتره بتغير
شخصيتي التصميم لطالما كل شويه ممكن اعيد
من البدايه وهذا شيء اول شيء هذا شيء جميل
انا اعتبره ان ان فعلا في شاقعه تتغير
وانت قاعد تتجاوب معها التغيرات ما انت
قاعد مشصب لا انا قلت ثاني بصير طيار ما
ما مغير هذا المهم انك انت تعرف نفسك
وبالتالي تغير التصميم انت كان عندك ذوق
معين تعرضت لاشياء في الحياه تعلمت ومرت
التجارب وخلاك تتخذ قرار انك تغير تصميمها
حياتك بحذر انه يكون بطريقه هذي انت كنت
عادات غير صحيه تعلمت انه هذا شيء ما راح
يكون من صالحي على المتل بعيد غيرت تصميم
نمط حياتك الصحي وصرت فهذا شيء انا اعتبره
مهم وطبيعي انه يجمع العمر ومع الوقت
فانا مثلا ماني زعلان انه ليتني اعرف عن
التصميم نمط الحياه وانا عمري 15 صعب جدا
انك انت تصمم في وانت ما زلت في مرحله جمع
خبرات وتتعلم عن نفسك وقاعد تعرف عن عن مش
قاعد يصير في حياتك رغم انه يعني مهم ان
ما نغفل الاشي واحنا صغار
اللي وعيت عليها وتربيت عليها القيم اللي
بنيت عليها لان هذه نقطه يعني جزء لا
يتجزا من انت كيف اصلا
هو مهم جدا انه يكون مبني ومنسجم مع
طريقه افكارك وقيمك وما تؤمن فيه وبعدين
الممارسات اللي قاعد تسويها بحياتك
فانا اشوف كثير يعني او دائما اعبر عنها
انه يعني نمط الحياه المثالي بالنسبه
للبراء يختلف عن نمط الحياه المثالي
بالنسبه لعبد الرحمن او لايمن او لشخص اخر
لذلك هو موضوع ما هو ارجع المثال البيت
يعني ذكرناه يعني مو كل ما في بيت مثالي
لكل واحد كل واحد له احتياجات مختلف
صحيح انك تقدر تقول في بيت جميل اقدر يعني
يعني على ذوقي اقدر استمتع فيه لكن مو
المثال الا تطلع فيه مشكله لو انت بتصمم
او بتفصل بيت على كيفك
بالاخير يرجع الى وجه القيام اللي تربيت
عليها غالبا
ومهم جدا في نقطه مره مهمه ان تكون
ايضا متكيفه معك ومع التغيرات لذلك احيانا
بعد خمسه عشر سنين عشرين سنه في البيت تحس
انك زي ما ذكرنا قبل شوي انه والله هذا
كان على تفكيري قبل 20 سنه اكيد بتضطر
تغير التصميم يمكن تنقل البيت ثاني او
توسع في البيت او تعيد في البناء او غيرها
يعني وهذه حياتنا يعني كل يوم كل سنه
ويمكن كل كل فتره مسافر على علي اني بكون
اكثر
علاقته
بجهدي واجتهادي على تصميم نمط حياتي هل
بياثر على
اني اكون
نمط حياه صحي بكل جوانبها في موضوع اللي
ذكرته اللي هو العمل اللي هو تصميم نمط
الحياه المهني
تصميم نمط العمل
ولاحظ اني قاعد استخدم نمط كثير
لان حتى هالكلمه اللي هي نمط
كذا بما احب اسميك شرط اللغه العربيه يعني
لانك
لانك تعجبني في شيء صراحه انك تحرص اي
واحد يكون فصيح في كلامه لا تقول كلمه
وانت ما تقصدها او لا تقول كلمه لانها
دارجه
فعلا لما تقول كلمه حاول تعرف وش اصلها
ليش ليش قاعدين نقولها هل هي فصيحه ولا لا
هل هي قاعده تستخدم في سياقها صح ولا لا
فهذا الشيء اللي هو كلمه نمط صدق قاعد
يقول احنا قل نمط حياه نمط ترجمه من لايف
ستايل اذا كانت هي كلمه الكلمه دي اصلا
فهذا لا كلام يمكن اجي بعد شوي لكن على
كلمه نمط نمط هو من الشيء المتكرر يعني
يعني حسب ما هو يعني في القاموس دائما
تلقاه حتى يستخدمون النمط او الباترن
بالانجليزي هي في الاشياء مثلا اللي في
الخياطه وفي الحقيقه يستخدمونها في مجال
التصميم في شيء في مبرمجين حتى يتكلمون عن
الديزاين هي
الانماط المتكرره اللي استخدمها لحل مشاكل
تتكرر معك برمجيه يعني فنمط الحياه هو
غالبا لما نلمس عن شيء يتكرر هو نظام
يتكرر
في نمط العمل لما اتكلم عن تصميم نمط
العمل انت قاعد تصمم وش طريقه عملك
الدائمه
[موسيقى]
فانت يعني قيس علي واحد فانت قطعا قاعد
تعيش حياه انا اعتبرها حياه جيده حياه
مصممه بشكل جيد
لا لا على الظاهر ولا على الداخل
[موسيقى]
رفاهيه يعني الكلام اللي تقول خصوصا يعني
حتى العلاقات يعني يمكن يجي الموضوع كله
بس يعني اول ما قلت العمل يعني استحضرت
الفكره هذه انه العمل مو كل الناس عندهم
هذه الرفاهيه في اختيار وين اشتغل كيف
اشتغل من مديري هو
يعني اذا لقى وظيفه فالحمد لله يعني خلاص
انا بستبر على مديري وعلى طريقه العمل
وخلاص يعني فما هي رفاهيه اني نختار كيف
اشتغل سؤال رائع لا صدق لان
انا كنت افكر يعني يمكن قلتها حتى في سياق
حديد الحين انه يمكن انا كنت في في نعمه
او او المشكله اصلا
كان عندي فرص وقاعد محتار وصرت افكر
بزياده عن
اروح ولا اقعد اختار هذه ولا هذه اسوي هذه
ولا هذه بينما الشخص المضطر
يمكن ما يفكر اصلا بموضوع تصميم نمط حياه
وكيف اسوي فهي
اذا انت ما عندك الاساسيات في حياتك قطعا
ما عندك السعه انك تفكر في تصميم نمط حياه
بشكل مثالي انت الان يلا بس قاعد تبغى
تبغى تنجم من الاغراض تبغى
تنجو بحيث انك تامل الاساسيات وهذا بشكل
بشكل يعني يعني طبيعي واتوقع منطقي
فكل ما زادت عندك يعني الموارد يعني
احيانا يعني اتردد في استخدام هرم ماسلو
لان حتى ماسلو كان معترض على فكره الهرم
لما اتكلم عنها لكن اعتقد شيء مشهور وكثير
ناس عارفه اللي هو فيه الاحتياجات عند
الانسان
في تحقيق الذات موجود فوق انا دائما اربط
تصميم مضط الحياه هذه جزء من الاشياء التي
تساعدك على تحقيق ذاتك
فبالتالي اذا انت امنت الاساسيات
بيصير اسهل عليك وبيصير عندك
ادوات وسعه اكبر في انك تصمم نمط حياتك
بالشكل اللي تبيه لكن ضروري جدا انك تبدا
بالاساسيات يعني حتى موضوع مثلا نشوفها
على سياقنا اليومي مع انه يعني شوي مختلف
لكن فيه فيل اوجه تشابه فيه هل مثلا اللي
يروح الجيم او اللي يسوون الرياضه في
الغالب يعني انا اجد انه في الغالب اللي
يشترك فيه جميع او يسوي رياضه هم ناس يعني
مقتدرين
ما تجد احد او يعني ناس عليها علامه
يقولون على الحد الادنى من الاجور ولا
مثلا العماله ما يروحون ما يروحون تقدر
تقول واحد يقول مثلا والله لان نمط حياتهم
يتحركون كثير ما يحتاج جيم اوكي ممكن لكن
يعني لما نيجي للحقيقه لا فعلا يروح
الجمره طب واحد يقول لا مو رفاح يعني صحتي
مهمه فهنا ندخل في شيء ثاني
الحياه مهم لكن هل تقدر تسويه وانت يلا
قاعد قاعد تامن الاساسيات حق حياتك اعتقد
انها جدا صعب ولذلك
لذلك هي تحدي وممكن من الظاهر تظهر كانها
مشكله يسمونها
مشكله الناس
المترفين يعني لكن انا اعتقد انه اي واحد
عنده اساسيات الحياه فهو متره وبالتالي
نعم يعني من الاهميه في مكان انك انت تسعى
في انك تصمم نمط حياتك بالقدر اللي تقدر
عليه
طيب ودينا خلف الادوات انت قلت انه بعد ما
بحثت وكذا انه ما كان اصلا عندك
ما لقيت يعني احد او محتوى يخليك تقدر
تعرف وانك وصلت لانه في ادوات في تصميم
فوش الادوات المتاحه
ببدا اشتغل انا الحين اقتنعت انه بس خذ
بيدي والله يعني الموضوع زي ما قلت لك هو
بحث طيب والبحث ما زال يعني قاعد يمشي معي
يعني من اليوم يعني حتى حتى اذكر حتى قبل
ما يعني
اول ما دعوتني للحلقه هذه كنت اقول خلاص
سولفنا قبل يعني بعدين ذكرت لي انه لا
بنتكلم اكثر عن التصمي الحياه وهو موضوع
انا بالنسبه لي ليس فقط اهتمام وليس فقط
موضوع بحث لانه مازال قاعد يتطوروا اليوم
يمكن اتكلم على ادوات بكره
صارت ادوات مختلفه بالنسبه لي وهي اللي
قاعد احاول على شوي شوي ابنيها واطبقها
وهذا الموضوع الثالث اللي هو اطبقها في
حياتي اليوميه
الادوات مختلفه متعدده واكثرها اما اني
اكتشفتها عن طريق التجربه وكذا جمعت شي
فكره من هنا وصرت اكون ادوات الخاصه فيني
او بعضها فعلا استله يعني تم استنباطها من
من كتب ومصادر مختلفه تكلموا عن تصميم نمط
الحياه لكن مو بالضروره باسم الحياه بعضهم
يتكلم عن تنظيم الوقت بعضهم يتكلم عن كيف
تخطط لحياتك بعضهم يتكلم عن كيف تخطط
مسارك المهني في اشياء عن اتخاذ القرارات
وكل هذه مواضيع تدور حول نفس الموضوع يعني
مهتم فيه
لو قبل ما اتكلم عن كذا ادوات بحد ذاتها
في صوره عامه كبيره او خطوات اساسيه لاي
واحد يبغى يصمم نمط حياته انه اول شيء
يعرف موقع الحالي اين انت الان انا اسميها
يعني اذا انت ضايع في الصحراء تبي طيب
يعني ما تقدر ترسم خريطه او تعرف وش تبي
تسوي اللي عرفت انا طيب
ولا في الصحراء الكبرى ولا وين بالضبط
يعني فلازم تعرف انت وين
موقعك الحالي
في حياتك وانت بتكلم موقعك الحالي انت
معناته انت قاعد تسوي تقييم
لنفسك في في عده جوانب الجوانب المهمه في
حياتي للتبسيط انا احب يعني اختزلها في
اربع جوانب صحتك اول شيء اللي هي الاساس
هل انت راضي عن صحتك ولا لا في كل بكل
جوانبها اللي ذكرتها قبل شوي او حتى لو
ذكرت الجوانب الاساسيه صحتك النفسيه
والعقليه والجسديه
واضم معها بعد الروحانيه هذه هذه شيء مره
مهم كل واحد يقعد مع نفسه هل انت راضي ولا
لا هل فعلا تحس انك انت
ومره ثانيه اعيد واكرر انت قاعد تقارن
نفسك
وش المقياس اللي قاعد تقيس عليه في ناس
قاسين على انفسهم
حياته جيده من برا الناس يقولون يا اخي ما
شاء الله عليك يعني يعني تشوف في المجالس
في ناس يقول لكم ما شاء الله
يعني جسمه ممتاز وكذا بس الا يب غى يشيل
هل
1% من الشحوم وفي ناس ما شاء الله يعني
مريحين يعني مبحبحين فهمت نرجع مره ثانيه
الموضوع جدا لكن
السؤال هو اين انت الان فهو تقيس على نفسك
الموضوع الثاني اللي هو بعد الصحه العمل
وين كيف في اين انت تقيم الاشياء هذه اللي
الصحه الصحه والعمل اللي هو ما مدى رضاك
رضاك عن عن عملك عن مسارك المهني في حياتك
عن عطائك للناس عن مدى القيمه اللي قاعد
تقدمها عن
تخصصك والشيء اللي تعمل فيه ما تجيده وما
لا تجيده هذه كلها اشياء تدور حول حول
موضوع العمل والمحنه وكيف تشتغل موضوع
الثالث اللي هو
العلاقات
علاقاتك وتكلم العلاقات هذا عاد بحر كبير
جدا من علاقاتك القريبه من اسرتك الى على
علاقتك بزوجتك الى علاقتك مع اصدقائك الى
الزملاء الى علاقاتك مع الناس اللي من
بعيدين عنك علاقاتك مع الناس اللي اون
لاين ولا اوف لاين علاقتك مع كل هذه كيف
علاقاتك مع المجتمع لحولك اعتقد انها يعني
مهمه جدا
وتاثر كثير في تصميم ومعرفه اين انت الان
في تصنيع حياتك واخيرا وليس اخرا اللي هو
اللعب ما مدى يعني الوقت او مدى
الحص الحظ او الحصه اللي تعطيها للعب في
حياتك كثير منا وفي مراحل مختلفه في
حياتنا
[موسيقى]
المشاكل الشيطانيه هي اسم لمصطلح للمشاكل
اللي كل ما صلحت شيء خرب شيء عرفت ذيك
اللعبه اللي يطلع والمطرقه تحاول تضربهم
فالمشاكل هذه هي مشاكل موجوده في الحياه
وموجوده في نطاقات كثيره يعني يعني حتى
يتكلمون عنها اليوم في في جميع الدول يقول
قطاع الصحه وقطاع التعليم هي من اعقد
القطاعات لانها دائما كل ما صلحت مشكله
خربت مشكله كذا نصلح المعلم خربت المدارس
المدرس الطلاب عندهم الاولياء الامور
مناهج والصحه اتوقع عندهم بعد قائمه تطوير
يعني فهذه يقولون دائما وكيف يحلون
المشاكل هذه حياتنا وسياق نمط الحياه هو
احد ابرز الامثله للوقت يسمونها او
المشاكل المعقده هذه لان مثل ما ذكرنا كل
ما حاولت تصلح شيء انت فعلا في شيء قاعد
ينقص في لعبك انت احب العبها بالسمز اسمها
اذا تعرفها في شخصيات وفي عندهم
نفس الشيء نفس الهذا ويمكن اللي يعرف
اللعبه يعرف انه انت قاعد تمشي في اللعبه
دائما كل ما سويت شيء في شيء قاعد ينقص
اللي هو يشبه حياتنا يعني
في مثل هالمشاكل كيف التعامل
ومره ثانيه هنتكلم كمصمم او كمصممين نحب
نحل مشاكل وهذا شغل المصمم بشكل عام لما
تروح عند اي مصمم مشكله انت عندك مشكله
تبغى تسكني في البيت فيه كذا عندك مصمم
ابغى اوصل رسالتي بمنتج او بشيء فانا بصمم
الانمي احل المشكله هذه اني انا يا اخي
مشكله كل ما راح كل ما رحت الشغل انا سحبت
على الصحه
كيف اقدر اصمم وكيف اقدر ادمج او اخلي
برنامج يخلي هذه الاشياء دائما في مكان من
الرضا
فهنا يستخدمون مع المشاكل هذه المعقده
اسلوب من الاساليب المناسبه لها اللي هو
التفكير التصميم الديزاين اللي يعني انت
يعني صار له رواج في تقريبا في 30 سنه
الاخيره يعني
هذا النوع من التفكير
يقال انه هو الانسب لمثل هالمشاكل لانها
مبنيه على خطوات او سلسله من الخطوات اللي
هي تبدا من التعاطف او فهم المشكله الى
تعريفها وبعدين لما تعرف المشكله وتاثرها
بالشكل الصحيح
تسوي لها افكار او تقترح لها الحلول تسوي
او نموذج اولي وتطبقها وبعدين تعيد
التعريف مره ثانيه وهكذا هذه الطريقه وهذا
الاليه تخلي دائما عندك دورات سريعه في
انك تصلح نمط حياتك او تصلح برنامجك الين
ما توصل للشكل المثالي اللي يتناسب مع
الفصل اللي احنا فيه وبعدين
الين ما يطلع طالع جديد وتعيد وتعيد الكره
بينما لو اتخذنا اسلوب اخر مثل مثلا خل
نقول اسلوب الهندسي الاشياء
الاسلوب الهندسي يتعب كثير وهذا تتوقع
مشكله كثير من الناس تبغى تحل مشاكل معقده
بطريقه واحده من التفكير اللي هو
تحسب كل شيء بالضبط ونرجع المثال اللي
قلته انا وانا صغير كنت احس باني بدخل
محاسبه طيب وخلاص يعني انا احب الارقام
كنت احب الرياضيات واحب احسب الاشياء وكذا
فحسبت او كذا اعتقدت اني بدخل المحاسبه
هذه طريقه حل المشاكل بالطريقه اللي خلاص
واحد زاد واحد تساوي اثنين وانتهيت وما
عاد
متشصب كذا تصير ما تغير او ما تحيد عن عن
هذه الفكره الين ما توصل هناك وتكون ضاع
الوقت وراح بينما اللي يستخدم اسلوب
التفكير التصميمي اللي هو دائما في تعاطف
دائما في فهم محاوله فهم لنفسك وش قاعد
يصير أنا قاعد يتغير في حياتي كيف قاعد
ايش اللي قاعد يصير في اين انا الان اللي
هو كيف قاعد يصير في
الصحه في الشغل وفي العلاقات حتى في في
وقت اللعب والرفاهيه اللي مره مهمه في في
حياتنا ما هي بشيء حكر على حنا صغار ولا
لما يكون عندنا فضلات وقت
كيف اقدر اعيد تصميم الاشياء هذه بحيث
انها تنسجم كل الامور هذه
فهذه اول نقطه اللي هو اين انا الان الان
مجرد تقييم بدون حلول تقييم مجرد اعرف نعم
لاني كنت
تحط حل على ايش اذا انت ما عرفت وين
المشكله فلازم تبدا تعرف انا وين الحين
اللي هو نقطتك الخريطه بعدها الخطوه
التاليه هي ثلاث خطوات الخطوه الاولى اين
انا الان الخطوه الثانيه اللي هي
وين اتوجه طيب انا اعرف انا الحين عرفت
اني في في صحراء الربع الخالي عرفنا انه
انا موجود هالمكان طيب وين اتوجه طيب هلا
توجه شمال اطلع ايش رايك قبل التوجه كيف
اعرف ودي اعرف ايش الاسئله او الادوات
اللي اقدر اعرف اين انا كيف اعرف اني انا
في الربع الخالي ولا في الصحراء
الكبرى يعني هل في اسئله معينه عشان اعرف
هل انا راضي هل انا صح وين انا هل هذه
مشكله كيف اقدر اكتشف المشكله بودي اعرف
اذا في شيء بكل تاكيد والله يعني
انا شخصيا
استخدم تدوين اليومي كتاب اليوميه عندي
الكتاب الاسود مثلا احد الاشياء اللي
اسميه الكتاب الاسود لان ما ادري هو سمي
الكتاب الاسود صراحه لانك دائما غلفه
بغلاف جلد يعني
هي عاده
اعتقد انها من من اكثر العادات اللي
ساعدتني او كثير في فهم نفسي وفيني احافظ
على السعي هذا الدائم انه ما تنفرط السبحه
واني كذا يعني اضيع او ما اعرف انا وين
الحين فهي خليني اقول اللي قاعد تساعدني
دائما يعلمني وانا الحين لان اضطر اني
يعني عندي اعاده احاول اني التزم فيها
بشكل دائم واحيانا انقطع لكن ارجع اكتب
وعندي فترتين في الصباح وفي المساء وش صار
اليوم
بدايه من الساعه كم استيقظت اليوم وش سويت
احاول اعبر عن كيف قاعد اشعر هذا الصباح
وايش قاعد اسوي اكتب فيها
سرد لي اهم الاحداث اللي صارت اليوم اهم
المواقف اهم القرارات اللي اتخذتها وليش
اتخذتها
اذا صار في شيء ضايقني او في صار شيء
اعجبني احاول اكتب احاول اعرف احاول اقيم
بطريقه غير مباشره المواضيع الاربعه هذه
هل صار اليوم في حظ من عده عناصر طبعا
الاربع عناصر اللي قلتها هذه عناصر عامه
بعدين يمكن اذا سمح الوقت في عناصر خاصه
صممتها لنفسي وفي مجموعه من الاصدقاء
حوالي صاروا يستخدمون نفس العناصر هذه
ممكن نتكلم عنها لكن هي هذه الاشياء اللي
قاعد احاول اقيم نفسي فيها فتعطيني كل يوم
شي ما ياخذ مني ولا عشر دقايق يوميا او
ربع ساعه
بالكثير بس يعطيني يعني علامه انا وين
الحين
وبالتالي هي التساؤلات اللي تساعدني اسال
نفسي فيها
يعني هذا علم علم على المجال اليومي في
تقدر تتكلم عن يعني لكل وحده من الاشياء
اللي ذكرتها
اعتقد اذا بحثت يعني على الاون لاين ولا
في اشياء كثير تجد يعني استبيانات تجد حتى
انا لما اقرا كتب معينه مثلا في هالمجال
سواء كان في مجال العمل او في مجال الصحه
انت لا شعوريا انت قاعد تقرا وتاخذ
معلومات جديده وقعد تتعلم اشياء جديده
وقاعد تقيم نفسك وتقول هل انا فعلا قاعد
اطبق هذا الشيء في حياتي ولا لا هل انا
هذا الشيء يعني قاعد تسوي تحديث
لمعايرك وبالتالي
الجي بي اس حقك قاعد يصير اكثر دقه
ممتاز الحين اين انا ننتقل الى الوجهة نعم
فاذا عرفت وينك تتوجه عشان تعرف وانت توجه
تحتاج البوصله هذا البوصله هي بكل
تبسيط هي تقاطع
قيمك اللي هو من انت مع نظرتك للحياه
مع نظرتك لي شيء مهم تسويه بشكل مره كبير
في حياتك اللي هو انا استخدم دائما نظرتك
للعمل
تقدر تستخدم نظرتك ايضا بالعلاقات ولا
نظرتك
للعب ولا نظرتك لاي شيء لكن دائما احب
ادمج نظرتك للحياه اللي هو عنصر اساسي مع
ناظرتك كل شيء مره كبير تستخدم بشكل يومي
او استعملوها بشكل يومي هذه انا اعتبرها
الحد الادنى من عناصر البوصه اللي
بتستخدمها اللي تخليك تتخذ قرارات في ايا
ما عندك تتخذ فيه شيء اليوم
وبالتالي يعطيك وجهه شوف اي قرار تبغى
تتخذه في يومك ليش ليش تختار انك تشتغل
ثمان ساعات بدل اربع ساعات تلاقي عندك
نظره في العمل المهم ان تتطابق مع نظرتك
الحياه خلت تتخذ هذا القرار ليش تستتمرن
الصبح تلاقي عندك نظره للحياه مع نظرتك
للصحه خليتك تتخذ هذا القرار ليش قاعد
تقضي وقت مع والدك او والدتك بشكل اسبوعي
ولا بشكل يومي لان عندك نظر للعلاقات ونظر
للحياه توافقت مع هالقرار ومع هالبوسه
اللي خلتك تختار انك
تحط هذا جزء من برنامج
وليس لانك قله احد ولا شفت بوصله احد
وقاعد تسويها وهذا اعتقد من اهم واكبر
المشاكل اللي اللي قاعد تسبب عدم رضا عن
الناس كثير احنا قاعد يمشي على بوصله احد
اخر او على بوصله ما هي بوصله ولما اتكلم
عن بوصله هنا يعني عشان ما يصير الموضوع
بعد
الغاز هي
وعيد اللي عرفتها هي قيمك وما تؤمن فيه
وافعالك
هذه هذه كلها تظهر على كيف تتبعك للبوصله
وتشوف واحد قاعد يسوي شيء مو راضي عنه
هذا هذا الطريق من هنا فيكون منطقي وقتها
لما تكون انت فعلا عندك بوصله واضحه وقاعد
تقارنها بالطريق
واذا كنت اسال يعني طيب كيف الواحد يسوي
بوصلتها انا هذه هي الاشياء الاساسيه اللي
اعتقد تبدا تصنعتك تجلس مع نفسك جلسه
واحده وتكتب فعلا ما هي نظرتك الحياه يمكن
بعضنا
التمرين او يعرف يعني قد جلس مع نفسها
تلاحظ ارجع مره ثانيه الى اللي هو معرفه
نفسك التعاطف مع نفسك اللي هو يستخدمونها
حتى في طريقه التفكير التصميمي اللي هي
جزء لا يتجزا كاداه من تصميم نمط الحياه
اللي هو دائما دائما يعني وفي انفسكم افلا
تبصرون انا احس ان هذه لخصت اشياء جدا
كثيره مهمه في كيف الواحد
المهم دائما نعرف نفسه وش نظرتك انت
الحياه
معتقداتك وايماناتك الشيء اللي تربيت عليه
والشيء اللي انت تؤمن عليه تؤمن تؤمن فيها
الان
هذه كلها مهمه جدا
وفي اسئله يعني مختلفه تساعد الواحد انه
يكتب ويعبر عن هذه الاشياء مثل يعني انت
في فلسفتك في الحياه وش تعتقد الحياه
السعيده واش تعتقد الحياه اللي تقعد
تعيشها برضا او معنا بالنسبه لك بتلاحظ
انك قاعد تكتب اشياء وهذي يعني حتى لاحقا
يعني
اول مره كذا اجلس مع نفسي واكتب قاعد
الاحظ كذا انا صدق الافكار اللي قاعد
اكتبها هذه
وين بتتمعي وش اساسها ليش وصلت الاحظ حتى
بعدها وانا اقرا سير الناس اللي يحترمهم
مثلا او سير شخصيات العظيمه او او الناس
بطريقه غير مباشره كلن قاعد يكتب في سيرته
نظره للحياه ونظره الاشياء كثيره فانت لما
تلتقط هذه الاشياء يصير عندك تعبير مختلف
عن كيف تعبر عن نظرتك الحياه ونظرتك العمل
ونظرتك العلاقات والصحه
يعني كيف اعرف نفسي يعني تقول يعني حطيتها
كاني سهل صدق صدق ما اقدر اعرف نفسي
هذه هذه اعتقد مع احد المشاكل الثانيه
اللي
القول سهل لكن التطبيق سهل واحس انه من
اكبر مشاكل ليش احنا ما نعرف انفسنا وما
زلنا ولا ولا يعني ولا نصل الى المعرفه
الكامله
وهذه
اتوقع احد احد الفلاسع ما اذكر اسمه يعني
كان يلخص الفلسفه
كلها في
يترجمونها او اعرف نفسك يعني ان معرفه
النفس هذه من من اصعب
المنى اللي ممكن الواحد يوصلها بس في نفس
الوقت السعي لها شيء دعوائق جدا كبير على
كل واحد
ولانها صعبه ما هي متاحه للجميع من اسهل
الاشياء انك تهرب اصلا ان محاوله معرفه
نفسك
ليش ليش الواحد يجد صعوبه في انه ينعزل مع
نفسه ومع افكاره لان هي نوع من انواع
المحاوله انك تعرف من انت وش قاعد تسوي
مرضيك
فمن اسهل الاشياء انك تروح على طول تتفرج
شيء تفتح جوالك
تهرب عن تهرب بالعمل تهرب باشياء ثانيه
لان مواجهه نفسك ومحاوله معرفتها ما
قطع ما هي سهله صعبه على الجميع وبالذات
اذا انت ما تعودت او ما حرست او ما وعدت
باهميه انك انت تحاول انك
تكون وقف وقف تعال وش صاير هنا وتحاول
هالفقره انك تسويها بشكل متكرر وهذا اللي
انا قاعد احاول اسويه وارجع لمحاوله
الكتاب اليوميه او هالوقت المستقطع بسميها
جلسات العزله كذا معدات يعني وما تريد اذا
الخصها
اني احاول لو الحد الادنى من هذا الشيء
اني انا احاول على الاقل بس اقعد مع نفسي
اليوم اشوف ايش صار لان في ايام تجي صدق
حتى الربع ساعه هذه تروح وما عاد يعني
وانا اشعر فيها لما يتراكم يومين ثلاثه زي
اللي متعود على الجيم ومر علي يومين ثلاثه
مراحل الجنب في شعور ثقيل وصعب اذا قاعد
تحس انك انت ضيعت جسمك مع انه شخص رياضي
وصحي وكذا لكن هذا الشعور يعرف اللي اللي
يتعود على شيء ويقطع عليه لان هذا الشيء
فعلا قاعد يحافظ عليه بشكل صحي
طيب وش اللي يعني هل في ادوات تساعدني على
معرفه نفسي يعني ممكن ما اصل لها بس على
الاقل في مثلا عده ادوات بعضها اقدر عليه
بعضها ما اقدر منها التدوين مثلا صح هل في
شيء ثاني اكيد انا اشوف الاصدقاء من حولك
والناس القريبه منك اللي يصدقونك من اهلك
من من زملائك من الناس اللي تثق برايهم
اشعر انها من اهم الادوات فاسالهم انك
تسالهم تجلس معهم وتقول انا يعني مو بس
اسالهم تتفقون في مقايضه ايش رايك نعطي
بعض يعني
عن اشياء تساعد الواحد انه يعرف نفسه عن
طريق الاخر يعني بالاخير الناس مراتك يعني
بالذات من يصدقك يعني او من تثق بانه لن
يجاملك او يعطيك رايي خاطئ
فغير الكتابه والسؤال اعتقد هذه اكثر اكثر
ادعتين يعني في المتناول
اعتقد فيه بعد يعني انك تستعين بمختصين
اعتقد كثير من وانا شخصيا قد استفدت كثير
جدا في اول مره اجرب جلسه معها
يعني يسمون لايف او المرشد حياه
هم ناس مهيئين ومدربين بطريقه اسئله
انهم يخلونك تعرف او تكتشف نفسك
وتصل الى اعماق معينه مثلا ما كنت ربما
ستصل لها لو جلسه لحالك او لو جلست بتحاول
تعرف نفسك بنفسك يعني
فهذه ايضا من الاشياء اللي تساعد اعتقد
اذا اذا شخص يعني فعلا يعني متمرس وفاهم
في هالمجال يعني
والقراءه قراءه ايضا احد الاساليب اللي
ممكن تساعد
الكرسي اكثر من مره تقدر تعطيني
يعني معلومات اكثر يعني اكثر هل تقصد انه
في اليوم ولا اني اعتزل
مده اطول اسابيع او فيه
من الناس برضو المعروفين اعتزل الناس
سنوات
وين العزله وش العزله بالضبط وش المفترض
تكون والشكل على المثالي
اذا كانت الاداء هو انا اسمي العزله ما هي
فقط اداه هي احب اسميها عنصر من من عده
عناصر طيب يعني اذا بحاول بس اعطي عنها
سياقه لو بسيط دوام اتكلم عن العزله
لان ما ينطبق على العزله ينطبق على
العناصر الثانيه اللي بتكلم عنها عناصر
العناصر هذه خليني اشبهها شفت كيف احنا
يوميا نحتاج عناصر غذائيه معينه يعني انت
يوميا تحتاج نسبه معينه من الاملاح من
السكر من كربوهيدرات من الدهون من الى
اخره فيتامينات يعني
على الاقل المعلومه العامه هي انه كل
انسان فينا يحتاج نسب من كل هذه الاشياء
اكيد احتياجك للسكر يختلف عن احتياجك
للدهون
اذا كنت في منطقه حاره عن لو كنت في منطقه
بارده مثلا اذا كنت صغير او طفل يعني اذا
كنت كبير اذا كنت امراه حامل مقارنه باحد
شباب رجال في عمر معين
فاحتياجات مختلفه وبالتالي العناصر اللي
بتكلم عنها الحين باتطرق لها في اسميها
عناصر قضاء الوقت هي ايضا مختلفه لكل واحد
فينا فاحتياجي للعزله يختلف عن احتياجك
للعزله
واحتياجي للعناصر اللي الاخرى اللي اللي
بسيردها سردا سريعا فمن العناصر اللي هي
العزله اللي هي اسميها قضاء الوقت مع
الذات وما تريد في عنصر اخر اسمه العمل
اللي هو قضاء وقت في
قضاء وقت في عمل وتلبيه حاجه اسميها وهذا
يعد لها تعريف ليش سميتها بالطريقه هذه في
عنصر من عناصر
احب اسميه خروج
بالخروج اللي هو انك تطلع للطبيعه قضاء
وقت مع الطبيعه مع الهواء فلما اطلع امشي
لما اطلع اركض لما اطلع اتنزه لما اطلع
البر هذي كلها انا اسميها كذا عنصر قضاء
وقت في خروج اذا قعدت يعني جلست فتره ما
طلعت في تكه كذا في شيء غلط قاعد يصير كذا
عرفت اللي عندي نقص حاد في الاملاح احتاج
اني اروح
فلازم اطلع رحله لازم اطلع حتى لو الحد
الادنى شفت كيفك انت اتكلم عن حد اقدم
العزه اني عندي ربع ساعه في اليوم في حد
ادنى من الخروج اني اطلع لو امشي عشر
دقائق
كذا في نمط حياه في في العناصر الغذائيه
او الحياتيه اللي يحتاجها عنصر الخروج هذا
المهم في عنصر من العناصر نسميه عنصر
تطوير
عنصر التطوير هذا اللي هو انا لا كل يوم
ودي اطول نفسي بشيء
ويختلف في ناس يقول لك ادخل معسكر تطوير
طيب وفي ناس يقول لك لا انا كل يوم عندي
عشر دقائق افتح دولينجو واتعلم كلمتين
جديده في اللغه هذه واقفه
او كل يوم عندي ربع ساعه اسمع فيها
بودكاست انا طورت نفسي في شيء معين مثلا
بس ما فنجان مثلا
هذا عنصر من العناصر ايضا في عنصر سادس
انا مدري ما عديتهم تقريبا ثمانيه
حطيته ممكن اي واحد يصمم عناصر اكثر من
هذه وفقا للاشياء اللي تهمك والاشياء اللي
تحس ان انت نمط حياتك يحتاجها ففي عنصر
سميه عنصر الخدمه قضاء وقت في انك تختم
وهو مختلف عن العمل كم كم الوقت انا قضيته
في اني اساعد احد في شيء واني اتطور في
شيء واني اسوي في شيء لما له عوائد كذا
يعني مختلفه ما اتكلم عن اجر ولا اتكلم عن
حتى حتى على الجانب النفسي ولا على الجانب
الاجتماعي ايضا
وفي عنصر من عناصر نسيتها عنصر اللعب طبعا
مهم جدا قضاء وقفي لعبه
واحرص ان اني اخصص وقت او اسوي اشياء حتى
لو دمجت اكثر من شيء
يدخل من ضمنها اللعب لان
اللي هو قضاء وقت في صيانه في صيانه نفسك
والبيئه اللي حولك احس دائما يوميا عندي
فقرتين من الصيانه اللي هو مقاومتك الصبح
تفرج اسنانك تتروش تتوضا تترتب المكان
تصلح يعني كل هذه الاشياء اعتبرها مهمه
جزء من قضاء وقتي في الصيانه
ويقدروا كل واحد فينا اذا عنده يهمه شيء
معين يصنع له عنصر خاص فيه ويقول مثلا
قضاء وقت في اذاعه مثلا يهمنا القراءه
مثلا انا ما عندي عنصر اسمه قراءه طيب
وعندي وعنصر تطوير بس لا انا معرف التطوير
الاشياء اخرى يعني تطوير مهاره لكن
القراءه انا تهمني فبحط عنصر اسمه عنصر
قراءه انا يوميا لازم عندي عنصر قراءه ولا
افراط ولا تفريط واصممها بطريقه معينه
فبالتالي
لما نيجي احد يبغى يطبخ طبخه اللي هون
اسميها انت قاعد تصمم يومك انت اختار
الاطباق
والقيم الغذائيه اللي فيها وفقا لاحتياجي
فعلا المجيء اصمم الاسبوع هذا او الشهر
هذا او رحله معينه اصممها وفقا للاحتياج
الفتره هذه انا من زمان ما صار عندي خروج
فكثر من خروج انا باطلع عندي اسبوع في
السنه هذا الاسبوع العزله مو بالضروره انك
انت في احد بس انه جرعات العزله فيها
كبيره فعندك معسكر معسكر عزله معسكر
معناته تاخذ من العناصر وبتكثر منه يعني
في الفتره هذه
حتى لا يعني لا اسهر فيها عشان ما تضيع
نقطتنا الاولى سالتني عن واعتقد اني جاوبت
بطريقه غير مباشره لموضوع العزله
حتى ما اطلع النقطه الثانيه اللي هي الوجه
البوصله هذه كلها
من الخارج ونرجع لشيء قلناه وممتاز المهم
اننا نكرره
يعني
دايما اقول اوفر كذا كثير كذا كانك قاعد
تحاول تحط بالمسطره يومك وحياتك وكذا وانا
اقول
يعني نظريا نعم لكن فعليا لا
لان
هذه الاشياء كلها
ومن طبعي انا يعني احترم واحب التنظيم
والمنظمين يعني واحاول اسعى اني انظم لاني
اذا ما سقيت وحاولت اضع من الوقت محاولات
التنظيم
حرفيا تتكالب الامور وتصير فورا وانا يعني
رغم كل هذا احيانا كذا لما بس اترك الزمام
الامور شوي الامور تتكركب وتصير فوضى
فترجع مره ثانيه لاول شيء
بالنسبه لي صارت الامور بعد ما مارستها
لاكثر من مره مو بس انا ومن حولي يعني من
الاصدقاء والناس يعني حتى
تصميم تشاركي بيني وبين عدد من من اصدقاء
القريبين
وحنا نطبقها مع بعض ونقارن مع بعض ونساعد
بعض ايضا في فلسطين
فهي شيء تصنع مره واحده وتحاول انك تعيد
العيار حقها اكثر من مره وتصير بالنسبه لك
طريقه نظر الامور فريمور كذا اطار يعني
تخلق فيه او تصمم فيه ايامك وحياتك
بالطريقه اللي تناسبك يعني على مستوى
اليوم
طيب لان كنت حطيت الحين انا بقفل العناصر
بنقفل كل شوي القوس عشان نرجع للقبله بس
العناصر انت اخترت الثمانيه عناصر
ثمانيه
[ضحك]
مثلا قراءه اعرف انها مهم بالنسبه لك وانك
يعني اتوقع انك تقرا بشكل يومي او شبه
يومي بس ليش ما حطيت من ضمن العناصر
يعني
كيف انت اخترت كيف وصلت لانه هذه العناصر
ليش
عنصر يعني هذا العناصر يعني حتى قصه شلون
صارت كذا هي مرت بعده مراحل من التطوير
يعني اذكر اول مره اصلا اخترعت فكره انه
في عنصر كنت اقول نرجع لموضوع في بدايه
انت سولف مع صديقي يمكن تعرفه دحوم عبد
الرحمن كنت اقول تخيل كذا الحياه المثاليه
بالنسبه لي حتى ما كنت تستخدم نمط حياه او
بشكل
حتى كانت في فتره المرحله الانتقاليه بين
البرج السعوديه بعد ما تخرجت اشتغل
باليابان ولا باكمل دراسه
فكنت كذا يعني اتخيل انه الحياه المثاليه
ابغى اقضي شهر في مغامرات كذا بطلع
مغامرات كذا اطلع شهر مغامره الحين اسميها
خروج
وبعدين بعد الشهر هذا ابغى اقعد
شهرين عمل
فلما ارجع من الرحله يكون فتره عمل اشتغل
خلاص كذا يعني عرفت اللي ريكاب بعد الرحله
بعد الشهرين هذه ابغى كان عندنا فقره اللي
هي الحين نسميها الشجره وقضاء وقت مع
الناس اللي هي فقره تسميها انك تطلع
للجمهور تطلع للناس انت خلصت عمل خلنا
نقول كتبت تعليم الرحله ولا سويت فيلم ولا
سويت ايا كان فتطلع للناس تقابل الناس
تحضر لقاءات تحضر بمناسبات اجتماعيه وكذا
لمده مثلا شهرين بعدها وبعدين بعدها عندي
شهر عزله خلاص كذا ارجع اروح اختلف كوخ
ولا في مكان بس اقرا وارتب واخطط حق
المغامره اللي بعدها بعدين اطلع بعدها
شهرين كذا يعني هذا طبعا
مثاليه غير واقعيه يعني بس انه
ممكن قبل التطبيق بشكل بس كانت هذه الفكره
انه في اربعه عناصر اساسيه في حياتي خروج
عمل
جمهور كنا نسميها
والاخير العزله
فكذا اللي فكره كانت لذيذه كذا يعني
وبعدين طبعا تكتشف قصور الاشياء هذه وباقي
حياتك وينها يعني الامور الثانيه اللي هي
الصحه
والتفاصيل الصغيره وبالتالي بدات تتطور او
بدا يطلع لها كذا اذاني ورجول الفكره يعني
لما صارت يعني وصار استيعابها انه ترى هذا
ترى الموضوع
اشبه مما يكون عناصر لا تنمط بالطريقه هذه
ترى هي عناصر ترى ممكن في الجلسه الواحده
يعني انا الحين
اخذ مثال لجلستنا هنا الان كذا انا ممكن
احلل هذه الجلسه ترى فيها اكثر من عنصر ما
هي عنصر واحد ما هي شيء واحد يعني انا
اعتبرها شجره لاني قاعد اسولف مع صديق
وهذا التطوير قاعد اطور شيء فيها عنصر
الخدمه او المشاركه انا قاعد اشارك معلومه
فيها عنصر يمكن يكون له مرتبط بالعمل بس
بشكل بسيط ما فيها عزله لان مو معتزل
الحين لكن فهمت والعناصر
تتطور مع الوقت وانت تشوف اللي يناسب وكل
واحد يفتكر يعني اذكر يعني بعض الناس اللي
جربت معهم هذا الشيء يعني كان جدا جميل
وكان بعد جزء منها للنجاح للتصميم كنا
نصمم لكل عنصر شعار ونرسم لها كذا تصميم
معين فكنا نسوي يعني اذكر في فتره معينه
كنت قاعد اسوي تجارب وقاعده اشارك
هالادوات مع مع ناس فيه على شكل ورش يعني
وكنت يعني انبسط لما اقعد في عدد من
المرشحون الناس يخترعون عناصرهم الخاصه
واحنا جالسين ويرسمون شعاراتها ويكتبون
تعريفها ويريدون يطبقونه في حياتهم
اليوميه وشاء رهيب وكل واحد قاعد يتعلم من
عناصر الثانيه او ممكن يستلهم من عناصر
الاخر يعني بما يتوافق طبعا مع نمط حياتك
وطريقتك وهذه العناصر تشكل قضائي يومك
وهي التي تستخدمها عشان تجمع مقابل يوم وش
بتسوي اليوم يعني بطريقه هذه ممتاز الحين
نرجع للبوصله او الوجه نرجع لخطوات
الثلاثه وقلنا الخطوه الثانيه اللي هي
الوجهه اللي هو بصناعه بوصلتك واتوقع اللي
خلاني نستطرد لهذه يوم سالت كيف الواحد
يقدر يصنع بوصله او يعرف نفسه انا اعتقد
انه فترات العزله واوقات العزله لتقضيها
مع نفسك تساعدك كثير في انك تبلور او تعرف
هذه الاشياء وحتى لو كتب نسخه اولى منها
وتتطور مع الوقت دائما ما في نسخه مثاليه
ولم تكون هناك نسخه مثاليه انا الى اليوم
ارجع بفتره فتره ما كتبته عن نفسي واشوف
هل ما زالت فعلا متماسكه مع بعضها هل
نظرتي للحياه ونظرات الاخرى للعمل
والعلاقات واللعب وغيرها منسجمه متماسكه
مع بعض وتعبر عني ولا لا انا قاعد اسوي
شيء مثالي او شيء ما هو فعلا او او ينسجم
حتى مع المحيط اللي حولي وهذه جدا مهمه
ننساها كثير اللي هو
نمط حياتك او او حتى بوصلتك تكون واعي
بمدى انسجامها ليس فقط مع ما تؤمن فيه
ومهما تفعله وايضا مع بيئتك المحيطه فيك
سواء كان هذا المجتمع او حتى اتكلم عن
البيئه
والمناخ والجو منسجم معه بعد ويمكن هذا
نتكلم عنه بعدين
فالحين تجي الثالثه نعم
اللي هو خلاص اذا انت صار عندك البوصله
لترسم الخريطه حقتك عشان توصل حنا الحين
عرفنا في الربع الخالي صار عندنا بوصله
مباشره تعلمنا انه ترى انا ابغى اوصل
الرياض فيقول الشمال هناك تلقى مدينه اللي
هي اسمها الرياض فتبدا انت تحط الخريطه
عشان ترسم كيف توصل الرياض بتاخذ طريق
الصعب ولا طريق سهل ولا طريق يجمع بين
الاثنين وهنا اللي يجي المواضيع اللي يمكن
طبقنا قبل شوي اللي هو كيف انت تخطط
يومك ويومك عشان توصل للي تبغاه طبعا هنا
يجي سؤال يقول انا لازم هل لازم اعرف اني
لازم اوصل للرياض لانه من الصعب جدا انك
تعرف او او يعني هذا اعتقد من واحد من
الاشياء اللي تعطل كثير مننا انه يحس انه
عالق او ما يقدر يتحرك لانه صدق مو عارف
صدق مو عارف وش الوظيفه اللي هو فعلا
يبغاها او المكان اللي يبغى يكون فيه او
الشخص اللي لازم اتزوج منه مثلا ولا وهكذا
يعني فطبيعي واعتقد مو مهم انك تعرف وش
النقطه الاخيره بالضبط الاهم انك تعرف
نقطتين هذه انت وينك وش قيمك واللي هو
بوصلتك وش الاشياء اللي تبغى تعيش فيها في
طريقك
يوم بعد يوم وهنا يجي اللي اسميها انا
رسم الخريطه او تصميم الخريطه او او انك
تحط الخريطه
فيه تمرين
رهيب جدا هذا التمرين واعتقد يعني او احد
الادوات هي ادوات كثير يعني لكل واحده من
الثلاثه اللي ذكرتها ترى في ادوات كثيره
بس احنا قاعدين نذكر يمكن كذا يعني بس على
سبيل المثال اداه او اداتين احيانا ففي
اداه في رسم الخريطه
تعلمته او سمعته في
بودكاست مع
اعتقد تم فارس كان يقابل واحده اسمها هذه
مصممه مشهوره وعندها وحده من اقدم واطول
البودكاستات اللي تشتغل عليها اسمها
وتتكلم عن التصميم بشكل عام
ضيوفها كلهم من الناس في عالم التصميم
والهويات والتسويق والغيره
فهي في لقاء فارس وهو ايضا هو شخص اخر
يتكلم كثيرا عن عن تصميم نمط الحياه ويمكن
من الناس اللي اشهروا هالموضوع يعني في
سياق معين يعني تحديدا في سياق العمل
كانت تقول عن تمرين تعلمته في في ام كانت
تدرس
من معلم كبير
يقول تمرين هذا
كان سحر في حياتها سويتها في 2007 وهذا
اللقاء كان في 2017 يعني بعد عشر سنين
من من التجربه كانت تقول انه هذا التمرين
كان مثل السحر عليها لانه طلب منهم في ذاك
الوقت انهم يكتبون
في قطعه واحده كيف تتخيل حياتك بعد عشر
سنوات انا الحين لو اسالك يا عبد الرحمن
احنا اليوم في 2033 طيب
اكتب لي كذا مقطع عن منتصف حياتك
اكتب كل شيء فتحت عيونك مش اول شيء قاعد
تشوفه من جنبك
فتحت ستاره راح سقيت الزرع راح تصحيت
عيالي عشان تجهزهم المدرسه فرش اسناني
خلصت كذا سويت كذا خلصت تمرين يلا جاهزين
طلع لنا بعدين رجعت رحت المكتب سويت كذا
بعدين رجعت البيت ترسم كذا انت صور
وتخيل اللي نمط حياه يعني تقدر تقول يعني
مو مثالي بس تقدر تقول انه هذا شكل من
اشكال الحياه اللي انا ابغاها اني اكون
عايش في في هذا النوع هي نسخه من نسخ
الحياه لان بالاخير ما في هي نسخه مثاليه
وحده في نسخ متعدده من حياه كل واحد يعني
ممكن يتخيلها وممكن يكون جيد يعني
بحط هنا توقف بسيط لان عشان اذكر مثال مره
مهم على موضوع تعدد النسخ اللي ممكن تكون
جيده لحياتك يعني قلنا للحين بنطلع نتغدى
هل في مطعم واحد فقط هو المطعم اللي ممكن
يكون هو المثالي للغدانه لا في عندنا ممكن
لو جمعنا القيم وش نحب وايش الاشياء اللي
احنا نهتم لها ما نحبها تتفلتر عندنا يمكن
خل نقول عشر مطاعم من كل الالاف المطاعم
اللي في الرياض اللي نقدر نختار منها فلو
رحنا لاي واحد منهم ما عندنا مشكله بنكون
مبسوطين نفس الشيء على حياتنا حنا الحين
ما عندنا كذا حياه واحده ياه لا عندنا نسخ
مختلف الحياه في في نسخه من حياه البراء
مدرس ولا دكتور في جامعه في نسخه من حياه
البراء مهندس في نسخه من حياه البراء
ويشتغل في التصميم في مرحله البراءه وهو
يسافر وباك كلها نسخ انا ما عندي مانع اني
اكون في اي وحده منهم لانها مرضيه بالنسبه
لي لكن مهم مثلا انك تقول لكن في كل نسخ
انا المهم عندي اني اكون معي عائلتي وعندي
ثلاث اطفال وساكن في المكان الفلاني وقاعد
امارس هذه هذه الطقوس وهذه العادات وهذه
الاشياء مثلا عندك حتى التمرين قوته وميس
لان يعطيك في بشكل بسيط بشكل غير مكلف
نسخه من نسخ حياتك اللي انت تقول ما عندي
مانع ان انا اوصل هذه الحياه اذا فعلا
يعني خطط له استمريت
فيستمر التمرين وتكتب فيها تفاصيل كثير
يعني
خلني اقول المحفزات او الكلمات المفتاحيه
اللي قاعد تساعد الواحد هو يكتب هذا
التمرين
ما يكون معالق انه يا اخي انا وقفت ما
اعرف طيب وش اكتب بعدين لان اكبر مشكله
تواجه كل واحد وانا تواجهني اول ما بديت
التمرين اللي قاعد اعلق على نسخه البراء
اللي يبغى كل شيء مثالي لا لا من جد يعني
طب انا فتحت من النوم هل فتحت ستاره ولا
كان ضغطه زر عشان ينفتح لا ابغى بالضبط
هل هل مشكلتك في الحياه ستاره لا خلاص
اكسب اكتب اكتب انا عايش في الرياض ولا
عايش في جده ولا عايش في
لندن ولا وين بالضبط
فهنا يساعدك على انك فعلا تتخيل نسخه من
نسخه حياتك نسخه من نسخه حياتك اللي ما
تمانع انك تشتغل فيها في معينه
والى اخره بشكل الاسره شكل علاقاتك شكل
الاثر اللي قاعد تقدمه شكل اشياء كثيره
والنسخه الاولى تخلق لك نسخ ثانيه السحر
في هالتمرين انك انت قاعد تكتب اليوم يصير
بعد عشر سنين عشر سنين بعيده يعني لو تترك
كل شيء الحين وتقرر انك يلا من الصفر انا
ببدا بروح كليه طب ومدرس طب ممكن تصير
طبيب بعد عشر سنين لو قررت انك توقف كل
شيء فهي بعيده بس في نفس الوقت تراها
قريبه بعد يعني هي فيها السحر هذا اللي
يعني
2013 ترى
يعني لو تفكر وين كنت تسوي ترى قبل عشر
سنوات هذه يعني تحس انها ترى قبل امس يعني
ومع ذلك
من اهم الاشياء اللي تساعدك فيها التمرين
ونربطها في موضوع البوصله مو البوصله
الخريطه
انه بيعطيك افكار كثيره او فجاه كذا من من
كونك انت ما تشوف ولا شيء الى انك صرت
تشوف قدامك فرص كثيره حلول كثيره وطرق
كثيره انك تسلكها او تختار او يسهل عليك
انك تختار الطريق مثل ما كنا كان عندنا
45000 مطعم فجاه صار عندنا عشره الاف مطع
اتخاذ القرار عفوا عشر مطاعم اتخذ قرار
عشر المطاعم مقارنه بالالاف اسهل بكثير من
انك
تضيع فلفل في العمر اللي كان عندك
فهذا الشيء اللي قاعد يساعدك فيه فجاه
تشوف الفرص لو تسوي كذا اعاده من نقطه
النهايه الى اليوم كيف انا اوصل لهذا
النوع من الحياه وتبدا تخطط لحياتك تصدق
انا شفت نفسي وانا عمري ذاك الوقت
46 سنه معناتها لازم اهتم بصحتي الحين
لازم اهتم باشياء معينه لازم اشتغل على
كذا لازم احط كذا ولازم اسوي ولازم فتبدا
تطلع لك الاشياء الصغيره او العادات
الصغيره اللي بتضيفها اليوم في حياتك
بحيث انك تقدر ترسم هذا الخريطه وكيف تقضي
وقتك في الاشياء هذه لما توصل هناك وبعدين
عاد في ادوات اخرى وتمارين اخرى كيف ترسم
فيها خريطتك اللي تتوافق مع بصلتك
ويوميا تعرف وينك انت الان وهل قاعد تقرب
ولا مو قاعد تقرب لهذا الشكل وهذا النسخه
من نمط الحياه اللي تخيلتها قدام
انا اتذكر يعني حاولت اني اطلعها على
السريع بس اني اتذكر
انا تربكني بس اني طالع الاعداد دائما
يعني هذا السترات
دائما ما اقدر اطالع الاداب بسهوله لاني
اشعر انك لما انا اطالع السؤال
تعتقد اني تبدا تختصر
بس في نفس الوقت انا فعلا
يعني نختصر ولا ناخذ الحق ايضا الفكره
فاذا حسيت انه في فكره ما شبعت ارجوك
ان هذا التوتر يصير عاده صعب اني اقدر
ارجع وادور على حاجه معينه ذكرتها
بس انت قلت انا ما ادري والله حاجه ثانيه
بس كانت تقول
ان يعني هي تساعد في تحديد الخريطه بدي بس
اخذ رايك فيها كانت تقول ان عشر سنين
بعيده
هو ماذا لو اتوقع كانت فكره التمرين كذا
بس اني ما اقدر اطلعها بسرعه
ما ادري انك بتموت بعد سنتين
باقي لك في حياتك سنتين فقط ايش بتسوي لان
سنتين مره قريبه تقدر تعرف ايش يصير صح
فانت الان تعرف ايش الاولويات مباشره تقدر
تعرف انا سنتين
هل انت باقي بتسوي هذا هل باقي تركز على
عملك وتترك اهلك هل اهلك بيصيروا هم
الاولويه الاكبر هل كل شيء يعني
بتخليك قادر على تقدير الاولويات بشكل اهم
بس ما ادري اذا بيهضمها لانها
صحيح يعني مره ثانيه انا اتكلم عن ادوات
هنا عشره سنين هو رقم يعني كذا يعني هل
بيتغير لو خليتها خمس سنين ولا ثمانيه
سنين ولا يعني وطرق التخطيط يعني
بدات موضوع الخريطه احسن من اكثر من اكثر
الخطوات من خطوات الثلاثه تمارين متعدده
واللي واللي ناس كثير يعني تخطط يعني كثير
من يمارس اصلا التصميم نمط الحياه
نسميه تخطيط
بجدول بسوي جدول بنسوي
مو بخطا بس مسميات يعني مره ثانيه يعني
مهم جدا لما يعطي الشيء اسم يساعدك على
على التفكير في يساعدك على فهمها اكثر
يساعدك على تفكيكه يساعدك على يعني وضع
اهميه مختلفه
في موضوع الخريطه او رسمها واساليبها وهلا
اسوي خريطه على سنتين ولا اسوي على عشره
سنين ولا على خمس سنين ولا على خمس سنين
بس اسوي اكثر من خريطه ولا على يوم واحد
ولا على سنه كلها ادوات مختلفه وكل وحده
لها فايدتها وكل مفيد يعني كلها لها
ايجابياتها ولها ايضا يعني
نواقصها يعني او الشيء اللي ما تغطيه يعني
حتى على شيء اذكره في حديث قديم لنا يمكن
تذكر وهي من الافكار او خلينا نسميها بعد
وانا اول واحد يعني اقول لنفسي هالكلام
اللي هو بعد نكون
حنينين مع انفسنا يعني في في فقرات كثيره
اكون جدا قاسي واقول اليوم ما استغليت ما
استغليت اليوم مئه بالمئه فصير قاسي لاني
سويتها لا لا يعني دائما مهم الواحد يكون
متعاطف مع نفسه
ويعرف متى يشد ومتى يرخي بس هذه فكره مره
ثانيه فكره سنتين او فكره سنه بالعكس كلها
اشياء مفيده وتساعد على انك تعطي ترجع
للصوره الكبيره
وهذا هدف في سياق ايضا رسم الخريطه دائما
في تصميم نمط الحياه عندنا لازم نكون
واعيين على اي ارتفاع حنا قادم
في الارتفاع اليومي
في احيانا ارتفاع اليومين عندي تخطيط خمس
دقايق اقل من خمس دقايق يوميا احيانا اقل
يعني بس بس اعرف وش اهم الاشياء اليوم متى
اوقاتها لان في عندي نظام مجهزه من قبل
كيف اني اجهز لهالشي هذا او كيف كيف تشكيل
وضعي في عندك تخطيط سنوي مثلا تسويه هذا
تاخذ منك يوم او يومين في اخر السنه في
عندك تخطيط مره كل عشر سنين في عندك تخطيط
كل خمس سنين وهكذا هي محطات مختلفه بس
تكون انت واعي
ارتفاع قاعد تحلك وخطا انك تستخدم ادوات
ارتفاع ابو عشره سنين على ارتفاع بويون
للنظر حقتك بعد تكون مختلفه
فاذا انت على مدى يوم كانك في السياره
فتقدر تشوف في المدى القصير جدا ولما تطلع
فوق كل ما تبدا تبعد عن الاشياء
الصغيره وما تشوف الا الصوره الكبيره صح
وهذي تعطيك بس
بس هذه تعطيك الادوات الحين
وطبعا التمارين ودي نحطها تكفى ايمن يعني
كثير اشياء يعني
طيب بنحاول نحط ترسل لي اذا في التمارين
عندي بعض التمارين
رابط الحلقه
80 اللي يسهل ان الواحد يسويها بنفسه بدون
ما يحتاج وصفه وشرح بالعكس
وهي كثيره انا متاكد يعني تتكلم عن تخطيط
كثيره لا تنتهي لو يبحث الواحد ايضا يجد
اشياء كثيره يعني بعض التمرين قاعد اقولها
اشياء يعني انا جمعتها وعرفت عنها وما زلت
يعني ابحث والموضوع بسجون يعني الى اليوم
هو موضوع اهتمام وبحث
واعتقد الجزء اللي يخليني مهتم فيه ليس
فقط لاننا قاعد احل مشكله شخصيه او قاعد
احل مشكله الناس قريبين حولي واشوف كيف
اهميه الشيء لكثير مننا يعني انه نعرف
نرجع للسؤال اللي هو وش توصيل كبرت هل فيه
دليل او ماني واللي يساعدني اني اتغلب او
اعرف كيف اقدر اصمم حياتي ايضا لان في
جانب اخر مني الحين هذا الجانب جدا شخصي
بعد اللي هو
احب احب للتصميم وحبي للتنظيم
احب انظم الافكار ايا كانت الافكار وهذا
اللي خلاني احب مثلا اكتب احب اكتب
كتالوجات الاشياء او دليل للشيء وكيف
يستخدم دليل استخدام اشياء معينه هذا
اهتمام شخصي بحث ودائما احس فيه متعه ولذه
يعني كذا كنوع من انواع العمل انك لما
تمسك شيء معقد او شيء صعب او شيء غير
مفهوم
قطع صغيره وبعدين تكتب كذا ارشادات كيف
الواحد يقدر يركبه من جديد او كيف يقدروا
واحد يستفيد منه استفاده بقسوه صار عندي
اهتمام حتى مؤخرا في في كذا يحاول التقط
الادله الاستخدام واشوف كيف كاتبينها بشكل
جيد بشكل صعب هل استخدمه كذا طريقه معينه
ولا ما استخدم طريقه معينه
فهذا ايضا موضوع اخر كذا من من الاهتمام
في هذا الموضوع
وما زلت يعني اندمجت كلها مع موضوعين في
موضوع واحد يهمني كبير الان في نقطتين في
نقطه الشخصيه في نقطه خارجيه
الشخصيه اللي هي للشخص الواحد
هل ممكن يعني انا الان
يعني صار خلاص يعني متاخر جدا على اني
ابدا اخطط عمري 40 سنه
يعني اكثر القرارات اتخذتها وخلاص
فهل هذا يكون مفيد اصلا اسويه اليوم
قطعا وبالعكس
حضور التصميم في كل انا مهم في كل عمر
وفي كل مرحله ولا ينتهي لبنتهاء الحياه
يعني اشوف اللي يوقف اللي يقول خلاص انا
بعد بصمم كانه قال خلاص
نرجع لمثالنا الباقي على البركه الله يحسن
الخاتمه
لكن المهم في كل عمر بكل وقت يعني اذكر
في في جزء في احد رحلاتنا واحنا
نبحث يعني فتره من الفترات في
تحديدا يعني كان كثرت في 2018 2019 كان
كنت اعطي وقت كثير انا وايضا صديقي عبد
الرحمن في مشروع لنا اللي كنا نبحث فيه
مشروع ركض كنا نبحث فيه
نمط الحياه عند ناس مختلفين كان جزء منها
سرد قصص
ونجهز اسئله ونوثق
نروح نشوف حياتهم كيف عايشين وش اللي
خلاهم يغيرونهم ايش اللي خلاهم يصمون نمط
حياتهم بالطريقه هذه اغلب من كنا نكلمهم
كانوا ناس كبار في العمر يعني تجاوز
الاربعين والخمسين وبعضهم توهم يعني بداوا
حياتهم بعد ما تقاعدوا او بداوا تصميم نمط
حياه مختلف بعد التقاعد انه قرر انه خلاص
يطلع من هنا ويروح يسوي ياخذ له مزرعه ولا
ياخذ الكوه ولا بيته انا كنت اسولف مع
دحوم يعني هل هل هل هذا الحين مثال لو لو
انا رحت اخذت لي مزرعه بعنيزه وخلاص وقعدت
فيها معناته حياه مختلف ولا ولا لا لازم
اكون
يختلف في الموضوع يعني مو
فارجع اقول العمر
قطعا يعني ما هو ما هو شيء يخلي الواحد
يقول
تاخرت او راح علي الوقت
كل العمر وكل مرحله لها سياقه ولها
متطلباتها
ولذلك قاعد يزيد يعني يزيد اهميه اصلا انك
تصمم حياتك عند الكبر بعد وليس فقط ولد
صغير ميزه تكتشف هذا الشيء او هذا هذا
المنظور خليني نسميه من عمر مبكر هو ان
الادوات عندك
تساعدك على انك خليني اقول تستغل
ما تبقى من العمر اكثر من اللي اكتشفه
متاخر فقط لكن مفيده وفعاله في كل الاوقات
يعني قطعا يعني بس تذكرت ادم بطاينه كان
يقول ان كلمه تمارس الرياضه مره مهتم
باطاله عمر الانسان
فايش انت تسويه في عمر العشرينات ولا حتى
في
انه مره مهم ياثر على عمرك وانت 60 او 70
في جوده حياتك او حتى في صحتك
فكل ما قدرت انك تعرف وش تبغى تسوي من
بدري كل ما كان افضل الجانب الخارجي
الثاني اللي كنت اقولك اللي هو العائله
اصدقاء هذه الدوائر وانت مريت عليها مرور
الكرام ان بس ودي اني اعرف كيف الواحد
ممكن يتعامل معها فتصميم نمط الحياه
والتصميم يومك عاده اللي تبغاه يضبط بشكل
المثالي اللي انت تبغاه يتعارض مع ناس ما
راح
يعني تنسجم مع هذا
الجدول حقك اللي انت مخطط له فكيف تتعامل
معاه هل من الافضل او من المهم
والالزامي انه الاصدقاء والدوائر الضيقه
القريبه منك تكون
منسجمه مع نمط حياتك ولا لا يعني هنا بعد
نجي
وليش ارجع مره ثانيه لكلمه التصميم
ونرجع للتصميم ان التصميم مهم لانك انت
قاعد تحل مشكله الان نعتبرها في عندك
مشكله انت ودك تقضي وقت معهم هم ودهم وقت
معك لكن في عندك اولويات انت يعني عرفت
رجعت للباصره وشفت انه انا لازم اتجه هناك
ما اقدر اروح فانت بترتيبك الاولويات وش
الاهم عندي تقدر تخلق شيء يعني الموضوع مو
ابيض واسود يا ابيض يا اسود تقدر تخلق
بطريقه معينه بحيث انك انت
تقول انا مثلا عندي او عندي فترات ما بين
المغرب والعشاء اي واحد يقابلني اقدر
ارتفع الوقت عندي اوقات في في شهر معين في
السنه هذا اللي يعني ارجع المثال المتطرف
كنت اقول في شهرين تروح تقابل فيها الناس
بعدين تطلع مره ثانيه كل واحد وطريقته كيف
يبغى يصمم هذا الشيء بما يتناسب مع الناس
عاد في ناس مره يهمهم جدا انه ينسجم بشكل
عالي فبالتالي قاعد يضحي او قاعد يقلل من
الاشياء اللي هو يبغاها عشان ينضرب وفي
ناس لا يقول انا صحتي ولا شغلي ولا اهلي
او لا او اهم من مثلا
العلاقات اللي برا البيت وهكذا
هي متفاوته لكن ارجع مره ثانيه على انت
كيف تصممها بقصد ومعنى انك تخليها تنسجم
وهذه يرجعني على على شيء مره مهم يمكن
قلتها قبل واحس لانه مهم ودي اكرره اللي
هو ايش الحياه المصممه اصلا بشكل جيد لما
انت تشوف اي واحد مصممه حياته بشكل جيد
طيب نقول حياته حتى مصمم عمل بشكل جيد
مصمم علاقاته بشكل جيد
هو الشخص الذي تنسجم فيها معتقداته وقيمه
اللي هي بوصلته سياقنا مع شيء اللي هو
قاعد يسوي
اي واحد يجامل بزياده تلاقيه في حياته
بشكل غير جيد اي واحد قاعد يسوي شيء او او
عنده ايمان بس مو قادر يسويه تلاقيه اللي
يتحسر وتلاقيه زعلان وتلاقيه يتخلطه مو
قادر يوصل مو قادر يسوي هذا الشيء اللي هو
مؤمن انه لازم يسويه
بعد موضوع ثاني طب وش الحلول الحلول يا
انك تغير قناعتك او انك تغير افعالك
وهذيك كل وحده فيها شغل
كل اللي انا قاعد اقوله يعني في تصميم نمط
الحياه او كيف يعني اجد انه هالموضوع كله
ينسجم
مع بعض لما لما اقول هذه هذا التعريف
واحطه في نص بعيوني واذكر نفسي فيه دائما
اللي هو هل افعالي
وسلوكياتي وما يظهر مني يعني الان وما
اطبقه منسجم ومتطابق معها مع امه في
واعتقد فيه وطبعا الطبقه الثالثه اللي هو
منسجم مع من حولي والبيئه المحيطه فيها
هذه هذه يعني بشكل عام الان نمط الحياه في
يجيك يقول لك واحد يعني كل هذا الكلام
تقوله ممتاز حلو
بس انه يقتل الحياه يقتل العفويه حقتها
يقتل التلقائيه حقتها يقتل يعني هذا الشكل
من من العفويه اللي تصير مع العراق مره
ثانيه نقطه ممره رهيبه وعظيمه وفي محلها
لان هذا اللي ما اخشاه انا دائما لما اجي
اتكلم يعني انا بشكل طبيعي واضح اني متحيز
جدا على موضوع التصميم وعلى موضوع البحث
واعرف ناس يعني يشبهوني في هذا الشيء
فنقدر نتكلم الى بكره في هالموضوع
وغالبا الناس اللي تتشارك في موضوع حبهم
للتنظيم يعني
على موضوع نظم مخطط وحط وبعدين تيجي على
الموضوع على الموضوع اللي ذكرته اللي هو
انت قتلت قتلت متعه الحياه او محاولتك
للسيطره خلينا نسميها على الوقت هذه غير
واقعيه وغير صحيحه وانا اتفق تماما يعني
هذا اكتشاف خليني اقول يعني مؤخرا من قبل
قبل سنه
او سنه وزياده شويه يعني اذكر اللحظه اللي
اللي فعلا كنت
بديت اغير حتى لغتي في طريقه كلامي عن
الوقت يعني اول كنت اقول كنت يعني اتكلم
عن ليش انا اصلا نمط حياتي لاني ابغى
اسيطر على وقتي كنت اقول كنت اقولها
الكلام
الين ما بدات تستوعب انه لحظه وين ترى ما
تقعد تسيطر على وقتي ما تقعد تسيطر على ما
حد يعرف ايش بيصير قدام هذا اول شيء
والشيء الثاني اي شيء تحاول
تسيطر عليه واتكلم فيه سياق هنا تخنقه كذا
اللي تحاول تخلي كل شيء يمشي على المسطره
وزي ما تبي مايكنت على كل شيء راح تتعب
وتتعب من حولك
وراح فعلا تقتل المتعه
في حياتك وعفويتها هذا نفس الشيء كان يصير
معي في السفر ممكن تخطط للسفر
في جزء من من مراحل الحب للسفر يعني كنت
اخطط يوميا بالساعه وش يصير طيب وبعدين
تيجي الارض الواقع وتصير تصير انت كذا تحت
ضغط لا نتاخر بسرعه خلنا نطلع من هنا
خلينا نسوي كذا
يعني
وبعدين بدات تكتشف انه لا ترى فيه وزنيه
مثال يعني وزنيه لذيذه كذا يعني في النص
اني أسميها انك تحط الاشياء العامه تحط
الاطر العامه تحط نسميها
ارشادي ترى هذا هو شكل الشيء
المثالي بالنسبه لي لكن ترى في مساحه من
الاريحيه عادي لو ما سويت كذا وهذا الان
لما اخطط يومي انا عندي شي يشبه الجدول
وحاط فيها وش يعني كذا بالساعات يعني عندي
هنا ساعه كذا عندي هنا ساعتين يعني ما
خطبت يعني اعرف ناس يخططهم بالدقيقه
وهي كذا اشوف انها كثير حرص تنظيم حلو بس
انه عادي يعني عادي الواحد يكون متبحبح
كده بدرجه متوازنه ومره ثانيه ارجع لموضوع
شخصي في ناس ما عنده مانع ما عاد يعني ما
بتنظيمة بدقيقه بالعكس يرى انه انضباط
والتزام وشيء جيد وهنيئا له بالعكس ممتاز
يعني اذا كان قادر على انه يلتزم فيه بدون
ما يقتل متعته فيها وفي ناس تنظيم
بالساعات هذا
وش اسوي اليوم وخلاص لا تكثر علي يعني
وهذا ايضا اسلوب وطريق يعني لكن اذا كان
هذا بينظمك او بيساعدك على انك فعلا تحافظ
على يعني اتكلم ما تخنق وقتك بس فيه نوع
من انك انت قاعد تتحكم او قاعد تسيطر على
وقتها مو قاعد يضيع خليني اقول يعني هنا
هنا السيطره اللي انا ابغى فعلا اتكلم
عنها
اللي يقول لك المهمه اللي انا اسويها
انها ما بيقدر ينفذها
يعني فكنت ايش اسوي انا في تطبيق
[موسيقى]
الايفون
وغالي لكن
لكن ما ستستخدم كثير يغير استخدامنا
يقول له بحط المهمه لهذا اليوم
علشان البسويها
واكتشف يعني في الاخير يوم واحد ما في
مهمه اكيد لقاء مع البراء بكتب مراجعه
يعني نقاش قبل الحلقه وبعدين عندي عندي
اليوم لقائين اللقاح
هذه وانا اريد كتبت اني انا ابغى اسوي
بكتب مدري شو واضح يوم الخميس ويوم الخميس
دائما يكون خفيف انا اعرف اني دائما
انه يوم الخميس بسوي بكتب المقاله هذه
بعدين بروح اقابل مثلا واكتشف انه فعلا
هذه المهام انا مستحيل اسويها
لليوم الثاني لليوم الثاني اليوم الثاني
واليوم الثاني فيه مهام ثاني
فيسل عليك انك تتخيل فيها
وقت يسوي المهام مستحيل
طيب يعني لو بتكلم معك على هذه الحين
مشكله طيب طيب نبغى نحلها المشكله جذر
المشكله هذه
تتخيل انك تقدر تسوي كل هذه المهام في يوم
واحد حلو فانت طبيعه اليوم مستحيله ففي
صعوبه فيه او خلينا نقول في عدم دقه في
تقدير حجم المهمه او الوقت اللي ممكن
تستغرق المهمه او الجهد اللي ممكن تستغرب
فهذا الحين انا بالنسبه لي كذا خلاص تعلمت
سجن من اليوم علامه انه ابغى اكون
حذر او دقيق اكثر في تقدير المهمه هذه هل
بتاخذ كثير ولا شوي فبالتالي طيب هل اقدر
اخلص هل لو اعطي المهمه يوم فقط اليوم
يكفي ولا ما يكفي فين في عاد استخدمه
مؤخرا لان انا ترى يعني بشكل مشابه كنت
اقع فيها الشيء وما زلت يعني احيانا لكن
صرت استخدم طريقه سهلت عليه كثير وصارت
تخفف علي حتى
انتقاد نفسي لما لما انجح في انجاز العشر
مهام اللي حطها اليوم ولا الست مهام حتى
احيانا
صرت احط يوميا في صندوق عندي يعني كنت
تستخدمها بس خلاص الحين
بالكتابه اكتب كذا بس في مربع وش اهم شيء
اليوم كذا عندي يوميا في صفحه الكتاب
الاسود فانا هذا في مربع صغير اسمه اهم
شيء اليوم واكتب هذه لو اليوم ما خلصت لك
اليوم اهم شيء عندك
احاول احط الاشياء هذي اخر اليوم اجي
اراجع واحط هذا تم هذا ما تم
وتصير احيانا انه الاشياء اللي تحت
الصندوق طيب يعني مثلا الحين انا كاتب
لقاء فنجان هو اهم فقر اليوم اللي ودنا
نركز عليها بعدين في عندي كذا مهمه احدهم
امسك خط الشرقيه طيب لو صار لي شيء وما
مسكت خط الشرقيه خلاص اكتب بكره امسك خط
الشرقيه مو كل يوم
بس واضح عندي انه اهم واحد فوق صار عندي
يعني انا بيني وبين نفسي قررت انه هذا اذا
ما سويته انا فشلت اليوم
لكن الاشياء الثانيه انا عندي تسامح انها
عادي تصير بكره واذا مثلا ما عندك تسامحني
انا لازم احضر فنجان ولازم امشي الشرقيه
اليوم
فهنا احاول احرس اني
ادخل اكثر في دقه على هذا فعلا قابل
للتطبيق ولا لا
بس انه يعني اعتقد هذا الموضوع يجي مره
ثانيه الى كيف تقدر الامور وفي
وفي بعد ايضا موضوع التنظيم في شخص قديم
ويتكلم عن هالمواضيع كثير اللي هو
من اوائل الناس اللي روجوا لفكره التنظيم
الشخصي او الانجاز وغيرها يعني عنده اسلوب
يتكلم عنها لان هذا المهام كثيره
وله طريقه وله نظام ولاح تصميم ولها كان
يتكلم عن نقطه اللي هو دائما تسرد كل
المهام في بدايه يعني
اسلوب بختصرها في انه تاخذ حاجه اسمها او
صندوق الوارد اي مهمه في راسك اي شيء تبغى
تسويه جمعها في مكان واحد ما يكون في مهام
اجندتك اليوميه يكون في مكان كذا برا
وتجمعها كلها
رحله سفر جمعهم كان واحد وبعدين في جزء من
العمليه هي اسمها
تحلل وش بيصير اليوم وتشوف من هذه من فعلا
منهم قادر اني اسويها اليوم وملي لا يصبر
البكره ومن يصبر
فبدال ما تقعد تشيلهم معك كل يوم
خليها بره نظامك وانت تختار اليوم انا
اشعر انه هذه مناسبه وهذه بتصلح واذا فعلا
خلصت كل مهامك وتحس انه اه تصدق عندي وقت
ارجع للصندوق
احسن من العكس اللي تحس انه ما يكفي او
انا حملت نفسي اكثر مني اقدر عليه مين
فكره انك تبدا تحطها في التقويم بتحط لها
الساعات المعينه فتكتشف انها ما يكفي
الوقت حق اليوم
حطيت لها ساعتين بس ترى ما امدا او فعلا
اليوم كان مشغول فاكل من
بس في حاجه
ليش صرت تكتب
بينما تقدر ليش تكتب يدويا بدك تقدر تكتب
الكترونيه
قصدك التدوين اليومي ولا هذا يعني حتى
اللي قبل شوي انت قلت
ما استخدم تطبيقات في المهام
يعني جزء منها طبعا يعني قبل كنت استخدم
تطبيقات كنت استخدم وما زال موجود عندي بس
استخدمه كذا يعني
في رحلات معينه في اشياء معينه اللي ما
اقدر اكتب كل يوم
استخدم تطبيق
لكن الكتابه بالنسبه لي
يعني اعرف الشيء اللي انا كنت اصنفكر فيه
وكل من يعني يستغرب لكل ترى فيه تكنولوجي
تقنيه
وتسهل عليك تسهل عليك التخزين البحث
الرجوع لها الكلمه معينه بس اكتشفت اني
انا ما احتاج انا ما ارجع ترى اللي ما
اكتب
[موسيقى]
فبالنسبه لي هذا الميزه اللي تسوق لها
التطبيقات او مثلا لو تفتح بجوالك تفتحها
في اللابتوب تفتح مكان ثاني
[موسيقى]
على طول اشوفها واعرف انه هذه مهمه وهذه
يعني احتاج اني اركز عليها وعندي طبعا
نظام بعد بشكل شهري هي الشيء الوحيد اللي
ارجع بشكل دائم عندي صفحه شهريه
[موسيقى]
دائما اصير بس اكتب لاني بس ابغى اكتب
طبعا اكتشفت اني احب الكتاب مؤخرا مره
يعني
الان
بدي ادخل على الموضوع يعني له علاقه
بتصميم نمط الحياه بس انها يعني هو بذات
الموضوع مهم احس ودي افرد له ساعات طويله
اللي هو اتخاذ القرارات
[موسيقى]
فتعرفني
مره مزعج يعني
ادري
[موسيقى]
ويعني وبحثت وافهم ان القرارات بكل
اشكالها
انها مزعجه وانها تاخذ نفس
الطاقم من اي اتخاذ سواء كان مهم ولا عادي
ولذا
ستيف ولا الناس اللبس نفسها طول الوقت ما
هو عشان نقول هو عشان ما يقرر فما ادري
بس ما اسويها بس ما هي هنا مثلا اسوا شيء
او ونتقابل
ناس بس لا يسالني وين نتقرب ارجوك لا تقول
لي
انت اختار المكان والمشكله انه اذا اختار
المكان انزعج يعني اذا ما يعجبني اقول له
اختار يقول هنا
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
مهارتك في اتخاذ القرارات
شخصيا يعني مثل ما انت يعني وانا
بعد وفضلك مره ثانيه اللي هو القرارات
القرارات شيء
كان متعب بالنسبه لي وهو يعني فعلا يعزى
اليه اصلا اهتمامي بالصينيه الحياه لان
انا كنت فعلا ما اعرف اقرر اخذ هذا الطريق
اقعد ولا ارجع اسوي
قبل تقريبا سنتين اذكر كذا وصلت
في وقت كورونا سنتين ونص تقريبا اكثر وصلت
كذا اوجه الانزعاج
وبنفس القصه ما في ما في دليل ما في شيء
وطحت على كذا مصدر
ابي اشارك يعني بعض ما اعرف عنها يعني لكن
اكتشفت اشياء عظيمه جدا وتخلي يعني وفي
نفس الوقت قاعد انقهر انه
يعني ما في احد ما في احد يعيش اني عايش
الان يعني وعنده مسؤوليات وما
يعني ما يقدر يستغني عن محل المهاره انه
يطور مهاره انا اشبهها ايضا بشيش يعني
يشبهها اللي هو الوعي المالي مثلا الوعي
المالي احس جدا مهم في معرفه كيف تدير
اموالك انتخاباتك استثماراتك كيف تخطط
ماليا كبسوله هذه بس مين علمنا الاشياء
هذه ما في منهج يعلمنا اتخاذ القرارات وما
في منهج علمنا الوعي المالي كلها اشياء
تتعلمها من محيطك من اسرتك من الناس اللي
حولك من تجاربك في الحياه من
الكفوف اللي تجيك يعني من وهكذا
فاللي يبغى مثلا يتوعى ماليا وما كان في
بيئه او ظروف تساعده انه يكون يعرف كيف
يفكر ماليا بيضطر انه يروح يتعلم ويقرا بس
هي مهاره تتطور ممكن واحد يصير يعني يصل
الى مرحله معينه من من الحريه الماليه من
التخطيط المالي الجيد من والى اخره نفس
الشيء القرارات القرارات انا بعد اشعر
انها اهم لانها هي ايضا اللي بتوصلك
للحريه الماليه اذا عرفت جيدا مع المال
اللي هو في الحياه بشكل عام
ازعم انه اغلبنا يعني وصل لما وصله من
مهارات اتخاذ القرارات بدون ما يعي اصلا
هو كيف وصل هناك او كيف وهل هو خطط لها او
صمم طريقه اتخاذ على القرارات يعني
وهذا الشيء اللي اذكر منك اكتشفت احد
الكورسات اللي اسمه
القرارات في التصميم
هذا يمكن تعرفه صديقنا صاحب
البودكاست المشهور بعد وعنده مدونه عظيمه
هو مشروعه كله يدور حول ما يسمى
بالمنتلمودلز او
الادوات الذهنيه خلينا نسميه او القوالب
الذهنيه اللي هي فكرتها كيف انت تتصرف
تشبه موضوع الادوات اللي تكلمنا الحياه
كيف انت تتصرف في فكره معينه بقالب
ذهني معين او كيف تكتشف انك انت قاعد
تنحازل شيء وانت المفروض انك تفكر بطريقه
مختلفه فهو يعني استطرد من هذا من هذا
المشروع اللي قاعد يشتغل عليه الى انه بس
خصص
القوالب الذهنيه او الادوات اللي تساعد
الواحد في انه يفكر بشكل اصح وبشكل افضل
مع موضوع القرارات هذه القرارات القرارات
يعني ويمشي مع مجموعه من المهارات
كل وحده فيهم تصلح لي لسياقات مختلفه زي
اللي يقول لك يلا هذه الحين صندوق ادوات
استخدم الاداه المناسبه في المكان المناسب
وطبعا ممكن تستخدم اكثر من اداه لكن اذكر
يعني من بديت اقرا عنها يعني اعكسها على
قرارات كبيره في حياتي وقراراتها ايضا
اللي بعدها بدات اشوف كيف انها الادوات
هذه انها قابله للتعلم كل واحد فينا وممكن
تساعدك فيه امور جدا كثيره واتكلم عن
القرارات الكبيره يعني
من ابسط واهم الاشياء اللي برجع فيها على
امثلتك ايضا ويمكن عندي الحين افكر بحلول
نستخدم فيها الشيء اللي تكلمنا عنه يعني
فيها
اللي هو
القرارات كلها يعني مو كل القرارات سوا
موضوع وش تلبس او وانتعك مو مثل القرار هل
اشتغل ولا ما اشتغل هلا اتزوج ولا ما
اتزوج هل ابي اشتري البيت ولا ما اشتري
البيت
نضع كذا القرارات كلها على على مسطح يعني
في بعدين محورين في محور
التبعات وفي محور التراجع هذه مهم جدا اذا
عرفت اذا عرفت الواحد يعرف يقرر كل قرار
ويحطه على هذا المحورين وين مكانها
انت ممكن 70% من قراراتك حليتها بدون ما
تسوي الابر تنك هذا او التفكير الزياده
اللي اللي يحطك في دوامه اللي قاعد يصرف
منك طاقه وقاعد يصرف منك جهد وقاعد يصرف
منك تفكيره في اي قرار اي قرار تاخذه
ويمكن ناخذ اي قرار على سبيل المثال شوف
هل القرار هذا راح تبيعات كبيره ولا تبعات
صغيره
اذا مالها تبعات كبيره
طيب نجي نسال السؤال الثاني هل هو قابل
للتراجع ولا خلاص اذا صار صار
طيب اذا هو ماله تبعات كبيره مقابل
التراجع كل دقيقه زياده تضيعها في التفكير
في القرار هذا
خلاص
اجزم توكل على الله روح طالما انه ما في
تبعات كبيره مقابل التراجع خلاص ما ضبط
الموضوع خلاص كنسلنا خلاص نرجع نرجع
البضاعه لا تسوي هذا طالما في شيء قابل
للتراجع وما لا تبعات كبيره
اعطني يعني مثال احنا بنتعشى اليوم طيب
نقعد نفكر ونرسم خريطه ونسوي
تحليل ساعتين ليه ترى بروح مطعم الاكل مو
بزين نطلع نروح المطعم اللي جنبه ولا نروح
مكان ثاني
فالموضوع وحتى لو اكلت اكل وطلع سيء يعني
لكن هذا ما حيقعد معك 70 سنه ترى بعد كم
ساعه يمشي يعني يروح
فهذي كلها اشياء فعلا حرام او ما تسوى انك
تتعب وتضيع جهد وقت انك تفكر وين نتعشى
اليوم لكن في قرارات مثلا مثل الزواج او
وين بتعيش الخمس سنين الجايه او شراء بيت
هذي كلها اشياء ثقيله يعني
تبعتها كبيره انا جوده حياتك على الوقت
لتقضيه على علاقاتك على طريقه شغلك على
تخطيطك المالي على اشياء كثيره
ففي الامور هذه اللي هي تبعتها كبيره وغير
قابله للتراجع او التراجع فيها مكلف جدا
جدا جدا الواحد المفروض انه يقضي فيه اكبر
قدر ممكن من جمع المعلومات بحيث انه يتخذ
قرار سليم واكثر
مشاكلنا او اتخاذ القرارات اللي نعتقد
انها قرارات خاطئه هي مبنيه على عدم توفر
المعلومه الصحيحه بذاك الوقت وسلوكيات
خاطئه اخرى
ما كنت تدري انه كان كذا
فهذه يعني يمكن فكره فكره عامه كده او كذا
يعني المدخل احد الادوات المهمه اللي
تساعد الواحد انه يعني يحسن من عضلات
اتخاذ القرارات اللي عنده واعتقد في اشياء
مره كثيره ومهم يعني ما زلت اجزم من
الموضوع
يستحق من كل واحد فينا انه في وقت جهد انه
يطوره لان ينعكس على حياتك بشكل كبير
وفي مقاله لهذه الفكره بتكون في وصف
الحلقه جوالك
[ضحك]
بالنسبه للقرارات اذا كانت بتقسيمك
الاربعه طبعا يعني فيه باقي كم حاجه بس
الاشياء الثانيه كل وحده فيها يعني انا
تكلمت عن عن الطرفين اللي هو غير قابل
للتراجع
والتبعاته قويه هذا اجراء مره مهم
والنقيض الاخر اللي هو لا تفكر فيه واجد
فهذه النقدين وما بينهما هو يعني
يختلف هنا
طرق اخرى كيف انك تخطط لها انك تقرر عليها
طيب كيف تقدر تعرف يعني هل في ادوات انك
تعرف انك جيد
اذا اخذناه انه هو بتفكير الادوات اللي
تخليك تصل الى قرار والله سؤال يعني بعد
مهم في كثير من الاحيان انا لما اسالك
سؤال مش اهم قرار اتخط السنه الماضيه مثلا
طيب مو لازم تقول لي بس اعتقد انه اول شيء
في بالك انت حكمت على القرار هذا بناء على
ايش
النسيه او جيد بناء على ايش اعلى نتائج
اعلى النتائج وهذه بحد ذاتها بطريقه خاطئه
في اتخاذ القرارات او انك في تقييم
القرارات لان انا ممكن طيب انا الحين جايب
السياره طاير بشاره حمراء قطعت الاشاره
طيب ما انصدمت
فالواحد لما يجي يقرر شيء لا يحكم او لا
يقفز على طول على النتائج لان ترى فيه
جانب منها جانب ما هو بيدك التحكم دائما
يعني تقييم القرارات او معرفه هل انت
اتخذت قرار صح ولا خطا يدور على الاشياء
اللي لها علاقه به وش اللي كان بيدك
وتحكمك هل كان يمديك تعرف اكثر عن عن عن
حيثيات الموضوع هذا ولا لا هل كان يمديك
انك تسوي شيء لرفع حظوظ نجاح الموضوع هذا
ولا لا هل ممكن تتخذ قرار يعتبر قرار صحيح
او قرار جيد او قرار سليم لكن النتائج
سيئه
تلوم نفسك يعني اذا كان فعلا حظك ذاك
الوقت او ما كان في شيء خارج سيطرتك لكن
هنا يجي من الاهميه اني كنت تعي وش
الادوات او ايش الاسلوب وهنا مهم للقرارات
بعدين مره ثانيه عضله ومهاره تتضمن مع
الوقت
وهذا احد انا احاول اسويها حتى في كتابه
اليوميه الان يعني بعد ما تعرفت على
العالم وحاولت اني احطك كجزء من من
الاشياء اللي ودي اطورها دائما اللي هو
لما اتخذ قرار
يتكلمون
او كذا فقط مذكره او مدونه حقت القرارات
هذه واحد فعلا مهتم بالموضوع انه يطور
قراراته ويبغى ياخذ المرحله مختلفه يعني
انه اذا في قرارات الكبيره يعني مهمه اكتب
المدونه وش القرار اللي انا اتخذته وش
المعطيات اللي عندي وش المعلومات الحقيقيه
اللي انا اعرفها وش المعلومات اللي انا
قعدت اخمنها او تراها طريقه تفكير من عندي
انا ما يعني عرفت اللي هو احيانا انت تاخذ
يعني تتعامل مع الاراء كانها حقائق وبينما
يعني كن منصفا يعني لا ترى في اشياء ما هي
حقائق فاعرف المصدر حقها بشكل صحيح او
اتاكد او تحقق في اشياء او في قرارات من
الافضل لك انك تاخرها قدر الامكان
وفي قرارات لا من الافضل انك تفكر فيها
قدر الامكان وتكلمنا عنها فهل انت اتخذت
هذا الموضوع التوقيت اتخاذك بالقرار بشكل
صحيح ولا غير صحيح الوقت فيه القرار كان
الوقت سليم كنت جوعان كنت معصب كنت زين
ولا لا اتخذتها في وقت صحيح هذه كلها يعني
وغيرها يعني من الاشياء اللي تساعدك على
انك تطور من عمليه
بالنظر للخلف على القرارات اللي اتخذتها
ولما وصلت كيف وصلت
واقفل باول ذكرناه المهم ان الواحد ما
يتحيز للنتائج في كثير من الاحيان يكون
التوفيق من الله يعني صدق يعني ربي يستر
عليك
وبينما لا يكون
تتاكد منه ايش الممكنات وايش الاشياء اللي
خلت تكتب هذا القرار كاسلوب لانك تراجع
مراتك ممتاز كيف تتعامل يعني عاده
القرارات الجيده يعني الناس يعني
يعني عمرها فيه سهل وما يراجعونه ولا ما
تفكر الناس فيه صحيح يعني لكن يفكر في
القرارات كيف تتعامل مع قرارات يعني مثل
ما ذكرت قبل شوي هل القرار السيئه اللي
اتخذ بناء على تقصير منك
على شيء انت ما فعلا ما حضرت لزين
ما يعني هل كان في استعجال هل كان فيه
انحياز المشاعر معينه بدون ما تتاكد من
اشياء معينه
فهذه يعني اعتقد هذه واحده من الاشياء
اللي ممكن تتعامل معها لو تذكر لي مثال
يعني بالمثال اتوقع ممكن يعني
الناس ترجع تشوف القرارات هذه
وما يعرف يعني شلون يتفادعها علشان تصير
عندك قرارات افضل يعني وخصوصا الاماكن
يدون انت اعطيتني واحده من المهارات
يعني واحده من ادوات ان تكون مهارات في
اتخاذ قرارات جيده اللي هي تدوين نعم فهذه
بيكون انا بدات تسويها او انمي بمهاره
جيده عندي فاذا في مهارات ثانيه تساعدني
فيها يعني غير التدوين انا اعتقد موضوع
المستشار ايضا عندك احد استشيره في بالذات
يعني اتوقف في قرارات مختلفه مثلا في
قرارات متعلقه بالمهنه مثلا في قرار
متعلقه بالعلاقات في مقرارات متعلقه
بالشغل
فوجود المستشار غالبا هو عشان يساعدك في
اتخاذ القرارات
وهذا الشيء يغطي جانب مره كبير من عندك
اللي هو مثلا المعرفه انك تعرف الاشياء او
جمع المعلومات او التاكد من الحقائق
بالذات اذا كان شخص خبير في مجال معين او
او شخص يعرفك ويعرف كيف
طريقه تفكيرك ويساعدك في
تمييز ما بين الاشياء اللي انت
عندك راي فيها او هي فقط اراء
وفكره شخصيه او حقائق حقيقيه واقعيه
فهذه يعني بس يعني سريعه اذكرها يعني في
الموضوع هذا على يعني وتذكرت شيء عن موضوع
كيف القرارات مزعجه لما تتكلم عن
وين نتقابل ولا
الاوقات وغيرها يعني
حدا مره ثانيه يعني في بعض الادوات تحتاج
لها ادوات لكن في طريقه معينه لتسهيل
الاتخاذ القرارات مثل ما ذكرت حتى في
بدايه الحديث عن القرارات اللي هو امثله
الاشخاص اللي عندهم قرارات مهمه جدا يبغون
يحطون كل عضلات القرارات عليها اللي هم
غيرهم فحاولوا انهم يحيدون يحيدون الشيعه
او يعينون او يعني فعلا يوكلون اشخاص
اخرين لاتخاذ قرارات اخرى هم ما يحتاجون
يفكرون فيها مثل احد يعطي نظام الغذائي
احد يسوي لك
لكن
في من الاشياء اللي تساعدك على اتخاذ
القرارات انك انت ايضا تحط تحديد او انك
تشيل تشيل عنك
الخيارات اللي تخليك اصلا تتخذ قرار مزعج
بالنسبه لك فمثلا على موضوع المطاعم ليش
ما يكون عندك انت فعلا ثلاث مقاهي دائما
هي الاماكن اللي ما عندك مانع لو اي وحده
فيهم
مقهى واحد معين او مقهى او مقهى تغيره كل
شهر عشان تتخذ قرار بدايه كل شهر يعني عن
انه هذا مكان جيد اي لقاء يصير هناك
ولقائاتي كلها بين الساعه سته للساعه
ثمانيه اعتقد انك تخليت يعني تخلصت عن كل
المزعجه وقطع وكلها اشياء يعني مثلا يعني
ما ادري يعتمد من بتقابل تبعاتها قابله
للتراج
ع لم ارجع انها تصير قناه سريعه زي ما اني
الان مضطر اني اخذ قرار سريع
شكرا لكم شكرا الحاجه في اعداد الحلقه
ومحمد نور شمت في التحرير والهندسه
الصوتيه محمد الحسن والتصوير عبد الرحمن
عبود والتلوين عبد المجيد العباس واداره
محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي
نوره السبيعي وفي اداره تحرير البرنامج
اسيل بعبد الله هذا فنجان احد المنتجات
شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع ننشر كل
الانتاج بحب من مدينه الرياض الاسبوع
المقبل القاك
يعني شلون تتعامل مع التشتت يعني امس كنت
اسولف
تركي
كنا قاعدين
قبل يومين حذفت انستغرام من جوالي يعني
تويتر موجود على جوالي
اقول لك جوالي فاضي اوكي واتساب ما في
تنبيهات كل التطبيقات جوالي الصامت
ومشتريته يعني مره احس في اشياء كثيره
تخليني ما اتشدد بس كنت اقول لا يعني احنا
نسولف كذا لا حتى اني فتحت الجوال يمكن
ثلاث مرات بس كده اشوف بدون ما تحس
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
كيف تتعامل مع التنبيهات التشتت
بالسوالف يعني احس انها دائما مؤرقه والله
صدق هذه مشكله مشكله عويصه ويمكن اللي
يعرفني عن قرب بعد يعرف
المشكله واحاول سعيد اني اقل منها اعالجها
اصلحها وكل مره شكل يعني لكل لكل موضوع في
في محاوله او شكل من من تقليل المشتتات
يعني
الاشياء اللي ذكرتها في الجوال احاول يعني
انا ما عندي اي تنبيهات يعني في الجوال
شيل الوحيد اللي يشتغل عندي هو الاس ام اس
والاتصال يعني كتنبيه
لان حتى كده بس اللمبه الحمراء هذه حقت في
رقم كذا في مخي تقول الا لازم اشوفه
احاول احاول اني فعلا احط اسوي للوقت متى
عادي افتح جوالي ومتى بعادي
[موسيقى]
الاوقات اللي انا عادي افتح جوالي ويصير
اللي اكون مرتاح مع نفسي انه عادي لو فتحت
يعني التشتت ما هو مكلف عليه الحين زي لما
الحين صدق ودي اقعد واركز على الشغله
واخلصها احد الحيل اللي قاعد تساعدني كثير
مؤخرا لاني صرت جوالي
اقول كذا احط التايمر اذا بكون متشتت
عاليه حط 15 دقيقه واذا احس ان اليوم امور
تمام اطول اكثر نص ساعه
ميزه التايمر هذا انه مثل يعني انت ممكن
تعتقد انه انت شفت نفسك ربع ساعه ترى وانا
اقول يعني عشان كذا كان الوضع سيء بالعكس
هذا الربع كل ربع ساعه في تشك يقول لي هل
انت ماشي على المهمه ولا
مجرد كذا طريقه تلقائية
بدون ما اشوف واكمل ايا كان قاعد اشتغل
عليه بينسياب يعني وهذه احسها ساعدتني في
اكثر من مره الموضوع التشتت وقت الشغل بس
ما ادري اذا فيه اذا فيه اتكلم عن تشتت
بشكل عام في
الحياه يعني لها سياقات مختلفه يعني
بصراحه اذا عندك دواء ولا علاج ساعدنا
يعني بس
يعني هو احسها مشكله يعني مشكله حياتك كذا
بشكل عام في الحياه يعني انه قاعد تكثر
واكثر معي الحين صار يتكلم بشكل عام
صار يحسن عنده جديد
يعني منه واتوقع دور مره كبير في
المشتتات والاشياء الموجوده عندنا اللي
قاعد تخليه ما يطلع الا اذا سويت
احسن الحياه تغيرت يعني مثلا ايمن ولا
اسيل يعني مستحيل كان يقدر يسويه
مستحيل كان يقدر يسويه قبل
يعني قريب لما اقول عشره سنين ترى مره
قريب ما يعني كان يقعد يسوي زي كذا بس
يعني
تركيزه عندك او انه مفهي وحصه التفهيه
حلوه يعني في مقاله تموت الافكار تطلع من
الحمام والله ما عاد صار تطلع من الحمام
في الحمام
يا الله يا الله يا الله كيف
يعني فعلا
لا لا بس بس والله يعني لا قصدي سلوكنا
يعني تعرفوا حسب موضوع يعني اذا بتتكلم عن
التشتت
وهذا شيء مؤخرا قاعد اكتشفه اكثر اذا
بتتكلم عن تشتت ما تقدر تعزل عن الدوبامين
واحس كثير من اللي قاعد يصير الان
مين اللي يقول لك اللي مرضيا عندهم
يعني تشتت حقيقي اللي فعلا عندهم اشكاليه
في افراز الدهميين او اتصال او يعني
طبيا يعني ما اعرفها وما متخصص فيها بحيث
اني افصلها بالتفصيل لكن اكثر من مره لما
اقرا واشوف وش الحلول وايش المشاكل تجد
لها علاقه بشكل مره كبير سواء انت كل شيء
تبغى تفحميلك علشان يعني هذه الحركه مصمم
البرامج اصلا عليها
واتوقع فيه وثائقيات ناس كثير تتكلموا عن
هالمشكله الكذب ليش الناس صارت مصممه بشكل
لاواعي في التطبيقات هذه لانها كل مره
تفتح الجوال قبل ما تجيك العائد كذا في في
مفاجاه بتجي
فعودنا امخاخنا على على هالشيء وانتبهين
طبعا معروف انه مربوط
بالاتمان واذا صار انت عندك كل شوي مخك
صار تعود على جرعه معينه وهذا ادخل مع
القهوه بعدين على جرعه معينه من يصير كل
شوي لا شعوريا يصير يبغى من اي مكان
من اي مكان سواء كانت من رساله واتساب ولا
بشوف الايميل ولا وش صار على الانستغرام
ولا تقفيل هذا القوي يعني
مو كلنا كذا احيانا تكفي يعني تذكرت كتاب
يعني على سالفه انها
[موسيقى]
المهم انه فكان يقول
كان يقول انه هو شال جوال وراح اخذ له ابو
كشاف شال اللابتوب واشترى له اله كاتبه
سواء كل شيء خطا
نفسي عن كل هذه الاشياء يقولوا يوم جيت
عشان ابغى اكتب يعني خلاص يعني
بديت اكتب قلت خلني خلني اغسل ملابسي
خلني والله
لا لا الفنانه تجربه
شو اسم الكتاب الاول هو الثاني والله
[ضحك]